Nein, nein, nein.
Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt.
Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt.
Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt.
Ich heiße der Pawel und der Sandro. An den Knöpfen bin ich. Ich heiß Holger. Und es geht heute in Sendung 120 um Zivilen Ungehorsam für Anfänger. Du bist zu leise, Frank.
Ich bin zu leise. Ich zieh mal mein Mikro ein bisschen ran.
Ich zieh dein Mikro ein bisschen hoch. Genau, ich zieh dich hoch und du dann ran. Pawel, sag doch auch mal Hallo.
Ja, ich bin hier.
Hallo Sandro. Bevor wir einsteigen, wollen wir noch mal Cottbus danken, dafür, dass sie die Wahlcomputer nicht kaufen?
Genau, wir werden so viele schreckliche Sachen heute hören im Laufe der Sendung, aber es gibt eine gute Nachricht. Cottbus hat keine Wahlcomputer gekauft. Sie haben sich gegen den Kauf von Wahlcomputern entschieden. Es ist ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, ob wir da jetzt dran schuld sind. Vermutlich ist es eine Frage des Geldes, aber ich denke schon, dass wir auch mit unseren Aktionen da auch ein bisschen zu beigetragen haben, dass die Entscheidung leichter gefallen wäre.
Wer es nicht mitgekriegt hat, der amtierende Oberbürgermeister der Stadt Cottbus ist unter fragwürdigen Umständen gewählt worden, nämlich mit Wahlcomputern. Das heißt, die Wahl ist nicht nachvollziehbar. Also die Stimmen sind nicht nachvollziehbar abgegeben worden. Jedenfalls nicht so nachvollziehbar, dass jeder hingehen könnte und sagen könnte, zeig doch mal gerade den Wahlzettel auf dem steht, wie abgestimmt wurde. Das gab einigermaßen Diskussionen hier im Chaosradio. Hier haben wir diskutiert, vom CCC sind einige nach Cottbus gefahren und wollten die Wahl beobachten, hätten das fast nicht gedurft, weil da ja auch...
Wobei es auch nicht so viel zu beobachten gab, weil es gab halt diese Kisten, die sind dahingestellt worden und danach wieder weggetragen worden und das war es dann mit der Wahl. Aber so dieses klassische, da werden dann die Urnen ausgekippt und die Stimmzettel auf den Tisch aufverteilt und dann werden die gezählt und jeder kann selbst eine Strichliste machen. Das gibt es da nicht. Da gibt es halt irgendwie einen Zettel, der macht so ein Zettel wieder ausgedruckt, und dann gucken alle drauf, wird schon stimmen, dann kommt der in Umschlag und ist weg.
Jedenfalls war da eine relativ große Berichterstattung. Selbst die Massenmedien außerhalb des Chaosradios hier, in diesem randstelligen Provinzradio hat es mal jemand genannt. Dem habe ich ja noch aufs Maul gehauen. Also auch die Massenmedien haben darüber Berichte, was die Kollegen der Abendschau, glaube ich, sogar, wenn ich mich nicht...
Lausitzer Rundschau.
Lausitzer Rundschau, siehst du mal. Na vielleicht hat es ja genutzt. Also lass uns einfach einbilden, dass wir es waren, oder?
Ich denke schon. Also es war vor allem ein Zeichen für andere Kommunen, dass es geht, dass man sich gegen diese Dinger entscheiden kann. Und letztendlich hätte Cottbus ja auch kein Geld gespart damit, sondern diese Dinger sind einfach teuer. Und die herkömmliche Wahl kostet zwar auch Geld, aber unterm Strich muss man diese Dinger wirklich schon viele, viele Jahre haben, damit sie sich möglicherweise irgendwann mal rentieren.
So 30 bis 50.
Vom Verlust der Demokratie aber mal abgesehen.
Was ich viel schlimmer finde, ist, wenn ich irgendwann mal mit dem Cottbuser Oberbürgermeister sprechen sollte, werde ich ihn nicht für vollnehmen, weil ich nicht davon ausgehen kann, dass er überhaupt legitimiert ist auf diesem Posten. Also das ist eben das Problem, was ich da sehe.
Vielleicht war es ja auch die Softwarefirma.
Nein, man weiß es nicht, aber weil man es eben nicht weiß. Also kann man ja nochmal machen, die Wahl. Vielleicht nutzt es was. Was war unser Thema heute?
Im, im, die kleine Revolutionslehre. Nee, ups, ähm, Entschuldigung, Ziviler Ungehorsam. Wir wollen heute mal sprechen darüber über die ganzen Einschränkungen der Bürgerrechte, die anstehen, die aber auch schon teilweise vollzogen sind. Wollen wir mit euch drüber sprechen, ob ihr davon merkt, wie ihr euch dabei fühlt und was ihr dagegen tut. Was man dagegen tun könnte, was man dagegen tun sollte. Wie viel man dagegen tun kann, also wie stark vor allem, wie doll man was dagegen tut und ob es da auch vielleicht Grenzen gibt.
Das war wahnsinnig abstrakt. Der Staat will uns allen über die Schulter gucken bei allem, was wir tun. Merkt ihr da eigentlich irgendwas von? Wir haben uns gedacht, wir steigen gleich mit der Frage ein in dieser Sendung. 0331 70 97 1 und so. Was merkt ihr eigentlich von all dem, wo euch die Bürgerrechte gerade weggenommen werden, wo uns die Bürgerrechte gerade weggenommen werden? Johnny Cash muss es ja nicht mehr mitkriegen, was alles so passiert in Zukunft mit unseren Bürgerrechten. Aber vielleicht kriegen sie alle anderen mit. 0331 70 97 110. Wie viel muss eigentlich noch passieren, damit ihr aufwacht? Also was merkt ihr eigentlich von dem, was ihr gerade an... Polizei statt ist immer so ein großes Wort, oder?
Nee, Polizei statt ist es nicht, aber es ist so ein schleichendes Gefühl, was sich so langsam um uns zwängt. Es ist wie wenn man so umarmt wird und derjenige drückt immer fester und immer fester. Und irgendwann bleibt ja die Luft weg.
Nicht weil er einen so lieb hat.
Nicht weil er einen so lieb hat, sondern weil er einen misstraut. Vielleicht misstraut er eigentlich wem?
Vielleicht ganz kurz, bevor wir richtig tief ins Thema einsteigen, wir haben noch einen kleinen Tipp für eure Sommerplanung, für eure Urlaubsplanung im Sommer. Nämlich im August findet mal wieder ein Camp statt. Das Chaos Communication Camp.
Alle vier Jahre nur?
Alle vier Jahre, genau. Und das ist auf einem alten Museums, oder auf einem Museumsflughafen oder ein Flughafenmuseum oder Flugzeugmuseum bei Finofort. Und ja, es findet statt zwischen 8. und 12. August. Das ist ein großes Camp, da bringen alle Leute, die da kommen. Es werden doch so ein paar hunderttausend, also nicht mehr hunderttausend werden. Ja, war die letzten Jahre sehr erfolgreich, sehr cool, sehr nette Atmosphäre. Es gibt Vorträge, Workshops, also so ein bisschen Programm. Also es ist nicht so inhaltslastig wie der Kongresses, also keine Veranstaltung, wo also wirklich Leute hinkommen, um sich da Sachen anzuhören.
Das ist auch beim ersten Camp und wir haben eigentlich nur gegrillt und gebadet.
Genau, und dass es zwischendrin auch mal ein bisschen was Sinnvolles gibt. Dafür gibt es ja noch Workshops und Vorträge und letztendlich kommen auch ganz viele Leute.
Und blöd.
Letztendlich kommen auch ganz viele Leute von den USA, von überall aus der Welt her und es wird eine große internationale Veranstaltung und die Atmosphäre wird mit Sicherheit wieder großartig.
Und wieder Internet im Zelt.
Genau, Internet im Zelt.
Ich habe mir so ein zwei Sekunden Zelt gekauft, das werde ich dann mal ausprobieren. Kennst du das? Das sieht aus wie eine riesige Satellitenschüssel, das schmeißt du in die Luft und wenn es landet, ist es aufgebaut.
Das ist extrem cool.
So ein Festival-Zelt. Darf nicht regnen und dann kommt es durch.
Die Location ist einfach super, kann man sagen. Die hat einfach Atmosphäre und so.
Es stehen eine Menge alte Flugzeuge rum und vielleicht kann man ja wieder flugfähig machen.
Gibt es eine Ankündigung auf der Seite schon?
Ja, auf events.ctc.de. Das ist unser Blog sozusagen. Und da gibt es jeweils immer die neuesten Nachrichten, was gerade so aktuell ist. Und es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, da alle paar Tage mal vorbeizuschauen, was es Neues gibt für die Planung. Und natürlich auch jeder ist irgendwie eingeladen, da irgendwie mitzumachen, sich einzubringen, sei es inhaltlich, sei es organisatorisch. Und auch da gibt es ein Wiki und alles Wichtige findet ihr auf events.ccc.de.
So, zu unseren Anrufern.
Wir hatten gefragt, was merkt ihr denn eigentlich von dem, wo wir gerade umarmt werden und wo immer weiter zugedrückt wird. Das ist eigentlich eine hübsche Formulierung. Malte aus Hannover.
Ja, Hallöchen, hier ist der Malte Fischer und wir wollen mal sagen, der Kongress war scheiße.
Kann gar nicht sein.
Das Beste ist, dass Malte Fischer noch nicht mal den Arsch in der Hose hat, dann dran zu bleiben, sondern so einen kleinen Schwanz hat, dass er einfach sofort auflegt, nachdem er rumkrackeelt hat. Naja, schade. 0331 77 97 110. Hallo. Kriegst du was mit von dem, was der Staat gerade fabriziert?
Fast. Ich hab heute nachgelesen im Internet, dass die in England jetzt durchsetzen wollen, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das ausdrücke, Röntgkameras oder Kameras, die unter die Kleidung gehen.
Wie soll das eigentlich gehen? Geht das überhaupt?
Ja, das geht.
Also ich kenne es nämlich so, dass es einfach bei den Fotokameras, dass durch den Blitz, für kurze Augenblick, also Teile der Haut unter der Kleidung, durchsichtbar sind. Und dass also die ganzen Metall-Speed-Kameras getestet haben, dass man dann tatsächlich während des Blitzes bei Frauen unter der Kleidung tatsächlich unterwäsche sehen konnte. Und ich weiß nicht, wie die es bei den Videokameras machen wollen, jedenfalls scheinen die durchsetzen zu wollen in England zum Schutz der Bürger, dass man irgendwie Bomben, Gürtel und Messer und sonstiges unter der Kleidung sitzen, also erkennen soll. Deswegen wollte ich fragen, ob die es in Deutschland auch schon wissen und wie sie es eigentlich technisch machen wollen.
Also technisch funktioniert es mit sogenannten Terraherzwellen, nennt sich auch Backscatter-Technologie. Und es wird auch tatsächlich schon eingesetzt, und zwar an Flughäfen zur Personenkontrolle in den USA. Es ist mehr oder weniger freiwillig gewissermaßen. Und man kann sich da im Prinzip sozusagen, man kann sich aussuchen, entweder eben komplett durchleuchtet zu werden, also bis auf die Kleidung, bis auf die Haut durch oder eben abgetastet zu werden. Und da hat man dann die großartige Wahl. Es gibt andere Systeme, das waren diese X-Ray Kameras. Sony hatte damit angefangen, da hat man im Prinzip mit dem Infrarotlicht und infrarot empfindlichen Kameras, also da musste man dann so den Infrarotschwerfähte aus der Kamera ausbauen. Damit konnte man auch durch. Das basierte darauf, dass die Kleidung für bestimmten Lichtbereich durchsichtig wurde quasi. Und wahrscheinlich vermute, dass es mit diesen Blitzlichten ähnlich funktioniert, dass es möglicherweise noch ein anderer Lichtbereich ist. Aber das, was die Briten machen wollen, oder was sie nicht mal machen wollen, sondern wo man darüber laut nachgedacht hat, dass es ja eigentlich nicht so schlecht wäre und der Sicherheit dienen würde, das sind diese Terraherzwellen und das ist im Prinzip wie ein Röntgengerät.
Aber sobald laut darüber nachgedacht wird, ist es ja eigentlich demnächst da.
Den Briten ist es zu vertrauen, ja.
Glaubst du den Deutschen nicht?
Naja, das ist sehr teuer und von daher bleibt es noch fraglich. Und wir sind zum Glück hier noch nicht so weit wie die Briten, was das Beobachten mit Kameras angeht. Aber ja, sicherlich geht das auf jeden Fall schon so weit.
Werden wir so weit kommen wie die Briten? Keiner sagt was, dann sag du was, Lev.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich denke mal, wenn möglich ist. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie es auch von Kosten her ist. Wahrscheinlich sehr hoch.
Nimmst du darüber hinaus, dass es in Großbritannien solche Bestrebungen gibt, auch in Deutschland irgendwas war, wo du eingeschränkt wirst?
Nein, jetzt genau nicht. Also konkret eigentlich nur wegen dieser Feier hab ich angerufen, weil ich hab's heute im Internet nachgelesen, also zufällig auf die News gestoßen und dann stand es drin. Und es hat mich interessiert, ob sie es in Deutschland auch durchsetzen wollen, weil ich find's irgendwie erschreckend.
Hast du schon einen neuen Pass eigentlich, so einen biometrischen, oder hast du noch einen alten ohne Chip?
Ich hab alten ohne Chip, also halt mit diesen biometrischen Symbolen auf dem Foto, aber bis zum 16.
Mal angenommen, es würde tatsächlich diese Bestrebung geben, das in Deutschland auch zu machen, also Kameras mit so was auszurüsten, würdest du denn irgendwas dagegen tun wollen?
Nein. Also ich, gegen tun aktiv käme es darauf an, wie. Also irgendwie Unterschrift, dann so, ja, aber jetzt so öffentlich auf die Straße gehen, würde ich eher nicht tun.
Warum würde ich dich persönlich dagegen schützen, wenn das irgendwie geht? Vielleicht so ein Bleimantel tragen oder sowas.
Na ja, also ich selber habe nicht zu viel bergen, aber mir geht es halt nur ums Prinzip. Also ich verschenke mir, dass jemand in Bombengürteln in Berlin umgestaltet ist.
Und jetzt Achtung, der Malte hat doch einen Arsch in der Hose. Hallo Malte.
Ja, Hallöchen, hier ist der Malte.
Dann erzähl mal. Du musst dem Typen nur sagen, dass er einen kleinen hat und Schor und Krieg sind zum reden.
Ich muss mal eine Spanzes retten, das kann ich doch nicht so stehen lassen vor aller Welt.
Was war denn am Kongress scheiße, Malte?
Was am Kongress scheiße war, kann ich dir sagen. Erstmal die viel zu hohen Eintrittsgelder. Dann unten im Hackcenter waren ein paar Engländer, die haben die ganze Zeit nur Party gemacht, einen riesen Müllhaufen hinterlassen.
Finden wir auch total scheiße.
Die Engel konnte nicht durchsetzen, obwohl wir die zur Hilfe gezogen haben. Das war alles so ein bisschen suboptimal, möchte ich mal sagen. Was ganz schlecht war, der Engelraum hinten ist ja schön und gut, aber dass dann die Hälfte des ganzen Hackcenters weg war, weil der Engelraum da hinten war, war auch nicht so toll.
Ja, das Hausplatz aus allen Nähten, das wissen wir, macht Vorschläge, wo wir in Berlin hingehen können. Das ICC kurz bevor es abgerissen wird, vielleicht. Aber da erzählen uns wieder alle, nee, das ist Westen und das ICC stinkt.
Entschuldigung, sie erzählen euch, dass es Westen, das ICC stinkt, da gehen wir nicht hin?
Ich weiß, da liegen jetzt zehn Leute am Radio.
Stattdessen liegen sie lieber in dreier Reihen übereinander, oder was?
Also das ICC wäre schon cool, oder?
Na ja, vor allen Dingen, wenn Malte sagt, ja da war viel zu wenig Platz, das war zu teuer, das war zu laut, das ist doch scheiße.
Also am Preis, da ist es nicht viel zu machen. Das Problem ist, dass es halt immer wieder Leute gibt, die meinen, irgendwelchen Unfug dazu machen. Und dann sind es einfach Kosten, die anfallen. Und letztendlich wollen wir auch, dass wir zum Beispiel mal Referenten, die kommen und irgendwie aus Amerika kommen, wenigstens auch mal irgendwie die Übernachtung bezahlt kriegen.
Genau. Und zum Preis muss man sagen, wenn man sich auf der Welt umschaut, dann ist es einfach für eine solche Veranstaltung konkurrenzlos billig. Also vergleichbare Veranstaltungen kosten das fünf bis zehnfache in anderen Teilen der Welt. Das muss man auch einfach sehen.
Das ist übrigens genau das Argument, was auch Bundesregierung oder Innenminister gerne nehmen und sagen, ja in den anderen Ländern, da wirst du viel stärker überwacht. Dann können wir das jetzt auch machen. Genauso mit der Mehrwertsteuer. Im Ausland zahlt man viel mehr Mehrwertsteuer. Da können wir sie ja jetzt auch erhöhen. Das, Paul, darf nicht das Argument dafür sein, dass der Kongress vielleicht teuer ist. Nur weil andere auch teuer sind.
Ja, aber wenn es Faktor 5 bis 10 ist und wenn man sich das wirklich anguckt, was dort über 100 Stunden lang einem geboten wurde an Referenten, an Aktionen, an Ausstellungen, an Möglichkeiten, denke ich. Ich meine, die Preisdiskussion ist jedes Jahr da, aber da gehe ich einfach nicht mit.
Was hat es gekostet dieses Jahr? Ich bin ja jedes Jahr nicht da gewesen. Hört mir jemand zu? Was hat es gekostet, Malte? Dann spreche ich mit dir. Die Jungs wollen nicht mehr. Was hast du bezahlt?
18 Euro für eine Dauerkarte.
Genau, vier Tage. 22 Euro pro Tag.
Die Location ist schon nicht schlecht, direkt am Alex, da kann man schon nicht meckern. Aber so organisatorische Sachen, zum Beispiel, dass die Engländer da unten Party gemacht haben, vier Stunden lang nachts von drei bis um sechs das Hackcenter rumgegrillt haben.
Total ätzend.
Und da nichts passiert, obwohl man sich das Thema beschwert hat und zusammengeschlossen hat mit anderen, dann die hausinterne Security da irgendwie eine Stunde lang rumgegammelt hat und den zugeguckt hat dabei, bis sie endlich mal tätig wurden. Also, na, das ist so eine Sache, das hätte man echt besser machen können. Es war also nicht gerade toll, da nachts sich so was anhören zu müssen.
Das haben wir versucht zu konzentrieren.
Warum bist du hingefahren, Malte?
Allgemein, um einige Leute zu treffen, ein paar Vorträge sich anzugucken. Und wenn man die Leute das ganze Jahr nicht sieht, da mal ein bisschen auszutauschen und so wieder.
Und die Vorträge waren die Kohle aber nicht wert, meinst du?
Ja, doch, zum Teil schon. Besonders Technologie und Pornografie. Ja, war doch echt nicht schlecht.
Um wieder beim Gemäch zu landen.
Wo wir schon bei der Ehre meines Spanzes sind.
Danke, dass du noch mal angerufen hast.
Ich wünsche euch einen wunderschönen Abend.
Dir auch, Malte. Zurück zum Thema. Die Frage war, wo spürt ihr eigentlich, dass gerade der Staat eure Freiheitsrechte einschränkt oder einschränken will? 0331 77 91 10. Wir schalten live nach Hohenschönhausen zu Axel.
Hallo, guten Abend. Hallo, Axel. Ganz zu Anfang. Es wäre ein schöner Traum, wenn wir die Flieger in ebersweite wieder dazu überreden könnten, dass sie fliegen. Leider gibt es da ein deutsches Kriegswaffenkontrollgesetz und das hat relativ final mit der Flugfähigkeit dieser Flieger Schluss gemacht.
Wieso? Was stehen da für Sachen?
Also der Topolab, der da steht.
Okay, angefangen von der Do134A, der Delta Mike, Serra, Charlie Delta.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Passagierflugzeug, was in der Interfluglange unterwegs gewesen ist. Über eine, nein, die ist weg, die ist seit 14 Tagen weg, eine L200.
Ich wollte gerade fragen, und das darf wegen des Kriegswaffenkontrollgesetzes...
Nein, die Do134A ist abgeschrieben. Aber es stehen drin eine MiG-24BN, die immer 724. Es steht drin eine MiG-21F-13, es steht drin eine MiG-21MF, es steht drin eine MiG-21UB.
Also alles Kampfflugzeuge.
Alles Kampfflugzeuge und die einzige MiG-21S, die ist in der DDR gehabt, die ist aber bei uns nie geflogen.
Was ist denn das Besondere daran?
Das ist ein Vorsälenmodell, die hat noch eine andere Elektronik, dafür hat der Segelzahn zwei Lufthutzen am Triebwerk hinten weniger, aber gut, jetzt sind wir echt weit vom Thema weg.
Ja, bei mich interessiert es.
Dann müssen wir uns da zu einer Privatführung treffen.
Nee, aber solange die Jungs nicht eingreifen, können wir uns nicht verlusten.
Ich suche gerade Bilder für Holger.
Da kann man auch viel mehr dazu erzählen.
Gut, zurück zu den Freiheitsrechten.
Zurück zu den Freiheitsrechten, ja. Ja, die Geschichte mit den Terrorherzstrahlen hat mich auch ein bisschen. Also dass es geht, weiß ich, wir machen sowas bei uns. Es werden bei uns diverse Untersuchungen mit Terrorherzgeschichten gemacht. Unser Speicherring ist eine relativ brauchbare Terrorherzquelle.
Noch mal für alle, Axel arbeitet am Bessie, also an diesem Teilchen.
Nein, Elektronenspeicherring. Kein Beschleuniger, sondern Speicherring.
Dann erklär uns noch mal ganz kurz, wie genau das mit den Terrorherzwellen funktioniert. Wir sind ja auch alle keine Physiker.
Die Terrorherzwellen sind elektromagnetische Wellen, so wie Licht, aber etwas langwelliger, wesentlich langwelliger. Und sie liegen im Prinzip im Bereich unterhalb des Infrarots. Das heißt, sie sind langwelliger als das Infrarot. Und überhalb dessen, was man so als Höchstfrequenz im Sendebereich, also im ganz normalen Funkmessbereich oder im Nachrichtenbereich oder Ähnliches verwendet. Da ungefähr liegen sie dazwischen. Sie heißen deshalb Terrorherzstrahlen, weil die Schwingung der Frequenz halt im Terrorherzbereich liegt. Terror heißt also 10 hoch 12 Herz.
Also sehr hoch. Sehr hoch.
Sehr hoch, aber wie gesagt noch unterhalb der Frequenz des infraroten Lichtes. Und es hat sich herausgestellt, dass die Strahlen in der Lage sind, relativ viel zu durchdringen. Es gibt auch positive Geschichten dafür. Beispielsweise gibt es weit verbreitete Ideen, an denen wird sehr intensiv geforscht, diese als Ersatz für Randgienquellen zu verwenden, weil die einfachen Körper wesentlich weniger Schädigungen hervorrufen. Für Zahnröntgen gibt es also schon erste Ideen und wir haben auch schon erste Bilder davon. Das ist ganz spannend. Aber dummerweise kann man wie jeder Erfindung so was auch zu einer recht finsteren Geschichte nutzen und so mehr oder weniger die Eindringtiefe einstellen. Ich kann also sagen, ob ich nur unter die Klamotten gucken will oder gucken will, ob der Kollege sich mal das Bein gebrochen hat, der da vorbeigelaufen ist.
Kann ich das verhindern?
Kannst du.
Klassisch würde ich sagen, Faradescher Käfig hilft auch da. Das heißt, du solltest dich irgendwie in was, in ein metallendes Geflecht kühlen. Aber das müsste ziemlich durchgehend sein.
Alufolie reicht?
Alufolie reicht, aber auch so ein recht feinmaschiges Kupfernetz wäre ganz nett. Aber wie gesagt, das muss komplett geschlossen sein, sonst funktioniert es nicht. Das heißt, es muss auf Füße, Hände und Kopf umschließen. Ist nicht ganz unauffällig.
Da müsste man den Modedesigner wieder auf den Kopf nehmen.
Für den perfekten Modedesigner, der sich dafür was einfallen lässt, dass du da gut getarnt erscheinst. Ja.
Habt ihr so ein Gerät, wo man mal so diese Abschirmung testen könnte?
Na ja, sagen wir mal so. Wir haben eine Strahlenquelle dafür. Was man dann damit macht, steht auf einem anderen Blatt. Allerdings sind die Experimentiermöglichkeiten dafür leider zur Zeit relativ eng besetzt. Es gibt viele, die damit probieren wollen zur Zeit, weil wir dazu unsere Maschine in einen speziellen Modus umschalten müssen, mit dem kein anderer was anfangen kann. Und das ist, wenn man so 50 Arbeitsgruppen hat und dann eigentlich nur noch eine befriedigt, nicht so richtig toll.
Wie schädlich sind denn eigentlich diese Strahlen? Wie ist denn da irgendwas dazu? Ich meine, wenn man so massiv in der Öffentlichkeit über all diese Dinge herumstrahlt?
Ja, das ist die klassische Frage, die man sich auch stellen kann. Wie schädlich sind Mobiltelefone? Wie schädlich ist WLAN? Wie schädlich ist Bluetooth? Der Frequenzbereich ist ein bisschen höher. Es gibt nicht so richtig finale Informationen darüber, ob die Schädigung linear mit der Dosis wächst, also vor allen Dingen im Niederdosisbereich. Ob es da einen linearen Zusammenhang gibt oder ob es eine Sprungsschwelle gibt, unterhalb derer überhaupt nichts passiert. Aber das ist wie die klassische Diskussion, auch über radioaktive Strahlung. Gibt es eine untere Dosis, unterhalb derer nichts mehr passiert?
Aber das weiß man dann, wenn es zu spät ist.
Naja, das ist so schwierig, statistisch das zu untersuchen. Weil wenn dann was auftritt, herauszufinden, dass es wirklich genau daran gelegen hat, also am Einfluss der Strahlung, die ich auf den Körper habe einwirken lassen, oder ob irgendwie der Effekt auch eingetreten wäre, hätte die Strahlung nicht auf den Körper eingefuckt. Weil wir reden da über statistische Effekte, so eins zu zehntausend. Das ist nicht ganz so einfach, in einem großtechnischen Versuch zu machen. Ich meine, wenn die Kollegen, Kollegen möchte ich mal lieber nicht nennen, wenn die Herren Engländer so was großtechnisch machen, gibt es vielleicht in zehn Jahren darüber Erkenntnisse.
Genau, das ist wie bei mobile Telefone.
Die auf der britischen Bevölkerung dann erfunden worden sind. Aber auch das wäre ja nicht ganz das erste Mal, dass man so was macht.
Das Beste war ja genauso, da wussten die auch von Anfang an, dass sie schädlich ist und haben sie einfach mal durchgezogen. Das wussten die von Anfang an und haben dann gleich die Tochtergesellschaften mitgegründet, die dann nachher es als Best wieder entfernen durften.
Ansonsten, was mich also so eigentlich primär erschreckt, ist, dass man immer mal an der Stelle was liest und an der Stelle was liest. Und dann von denen, dass sie die Datenbanken zusammenlegen wollen und die, dass da jeder drauf zugreifen kann. Mein primäres Problem ist, Datenbanken zusammenlegen ist ja das eine, aber ich brauche ja auch irgendjemanden, der die Datenbanken pflegt. Ich meine, wenn der Verkehrsrechner in Flensburg irgendwie eine Meise hat und der Meinung ist, dass ich irgendwie mit 90 durch eine 30er-Zone gebügelt bin und mir dann das irgendwie zuschickt, kann ich vielleicht noch relativ leicht nachweisen, dass ich das nicht bin. Und wenn im ungünstigsten Fall bin ich für ein Jahr meinen Hörerschein los, ist zwar nicht schön, aber okay.
Von der Schufa hört man ja gerne mal solche Sachen, dass da versehentlich irgendwelche Datensätze durcheinander kommen oder irgendein solcher Index berichten.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das sind nun relativ kleine Datensätze. Wenn ich jetzt europaweit eine große Datenbank kegle und ich dann in die Fänge dieser Datenbank rate und terroristisch verdächtig bin und dann plötzlich mein Interesse für, was weiß ich, für Funktechnik, für Kernwaffen, für was weiß ich, in einem ganz anderen Licht erscheint, dann hab ich da ein ganz großes Problem damit.
Ich hab immer eine Frage, wenn ihr mit dieser Technik, dieser Terror-Hertz-Technik bei euch auch experimentiert, hast du da auch mal Diskussionen mit deinen Kollegen darüber?
Eher selten, weil wir eigentlich Grundlagenforschung machen. Ja gut, aber trotzdem, also das ist ja... Es sind nicht so viele Leute, die das zurzeit bei uns machen. Es sind bloß zwei oder drei. Und die sind also froh, wenn sie irgendwelche wirklich grundlegenden Probleme haben. Wir sind immer noch ehrlich am Rudern, die Maschine dazu zu kriegen, dass sie die Strahlung in vernünftiger Qualität und anständiger Leistungsdichte auch liefert. Das heißt, wir sind an der Stelle noch relativ weit am Anfang. Es gibt diverse andere Teraharprofonatoren, die allerdings nicht so eine hohe Leistungsdichte haben. Bei uns kommt es ein bisschen sehr darauf an, dass das Licht, wenn gleiches kein Licht ist, möglichst auch noch sehr hell ist.
Aber wenn, mal angenommen, ihr seid insoweit und diese Technik wird dann tatsächlich auch mal auf den Straßen eingesetzt, wie würdest du dich denn dabei fühlen?
Bescheiden. Um keine anderen Worte zu nennen. Aber ich kann nicht, ich muss auf der anderen Seite auch sagen, ich kann nicht jede Forschung, nur weil man sie irgendwie zu etwas Schlechtem verwenden kann, unterbinden. Das funktioniert leider auch nicht. Und wenn ich es nicht mache, macht es einfach jemand anderes. Da komme ich nicht dran vorbei.
Na ja, aber es gab trotzdem in der Vergangenheit eine Wissenschaftsgeschichte, da gab es immer viele große Wissenschaftler, die an bestimmten Punkten sich dann gegen weitere Forschung entschieden haben. Es hat trotzdem auch mal eine persönliche Entscheidung. Das ist natürlich schwierig, auch gerade in der jetzigen Finanzlandschaft mit Wissenschaft, ich kenne das ja auch, sich so eine Einzelentscheidung zu treffen.
Und wie gesagt, also die positiven Nebenwirkungen, die man dabei zurzeit sieht, sind meiner Ansicht nach sehr groß.
Ja, ich denke in dem Fall, also es ist auf jeden Fall...
Also ich würde mich, glaube ich, wesentlich besser führen, wenn der Kollege Zahnarzt nicht mehr mit einer Röntgenkanone auf meinen Zahn drauf losgeht, zumal leider im Kopf relativ hohe Dosisleistungen unterwegs sind. Also Dosen und damit auch Dosisleistung, die Einflugzeit ist wesentlich länger. Und in der Nähe des Kopfes mit ionisierender Strahlung ist so eine Sache. Und da wäre ich schon wesentlich dankbarer, wenn der Kollege mit was anderem auf mich losgeht.
Ja, ich denke mit dem Messer.
Ja, das passiert ja hinterher.
Aber auch da kann man ja heutzutage mit dem Laser zu Werke gehen. Aber da sind noch nicht so richtig viele davon überzeugt. Weil sie sagen einfach, na gut, jetzt sind wir wieder vom Thema weg. Mit dem Laser haben sie einfach nicht das Gefühl, den der Zahn hat. Sonst mit dem Bohrer hat der Zahn, macht ja mechanisch einen gewissen Widerstand, wenn er mit dem Bohrer unterwegs ist. Force Feedback. Genau. Mit dem Laser hat man sowas natürlich nicht. Aber gut, ja, wie gesagt, mein Hauptproblem ist tatsächlich, dass ich meine echten Zweifel an der ganzen Informationstechnik dahinter habe. Und ich weiß, dass es theoretisch alles beherrschbar ist. Aber es sind trotz allem immer nur noch Menschen, die da unterwegs sind. Und je mehr Menschen dabei involviert sind, desto größer ist die Trefferquote für einen Fehler.
Und ja, da muss ich dir voll beipflichten. Das ist auch das, was mir persönlich am meisten unbehagen bereitet, gerade bei USA-Reisen, die ich versuche zu minimieren.
Ich versuche, mir ganz zu verkneifen.
Ja, aber es geht nicht immer ganz. Aber da bin ich schon in mehrere wirklich unschöne Situationen gekommen. Und das Problem ist, dass gerade in den USA zum Beispiel diese No-Fly-List, das ist einer der größten Skandale überhaupt, weil dort mangels ausweisen. Es reicht, wenn man zufällig so heißt wie irgendjemand, der auf dieser Liste steht. Und ansonsten ist auch generell in den USA die ganze Informationstechnik nicht besonders zuverlässig. Und ein Abgeordneter hat alleine...
Die Geschichten erzählst du nach den Nachrichten, bitte Pavel. Wir sind nämlich schon ein paar Minuten drüber. Danke Axel. So wie war das? Unschöne Situation, in denen du dich bei der Einreise in die USA befunden hast. Und die Geschichte von dem Mann mit der No-Fly-List.
Tommy Wosch, Sie sind mit Ihrem aktuellen Bühnenprogramm steif on stage im Februar und März in Berlin und Brandenburg unterwegs. Was können wir da als Zuschauer erwarten?
Gut, folgender Plan, wir präsentieren in diesem Winter eine bildgewaltige Multiamedashow der Extra-Klasse. Unscharfe, die als verwackelte Videos Gedichte, die sie nicht reimen und Wortwürze ohne Worte.
Und steht Ihnen noch jemand zur Seite?
Ich werde dabei unterstützt durch die Big Band der Karl-Bonnöfer-Klinik unter der Leitung von Jürgen Dringst. Hinterlader Reloaded. Natürlich darf auch meine künstlerische Nachgeburt nicht fehlen. Michi Balzer, das Radnur Witzfaktotum, ergänzt das Programm congenial mit seiner stinkblöden Art.
Tommy Worsch.
Jetzt wieder unterwegs in Berlin und Brandenburg.
Alle Termine unter fritz.de.
Und das hört man. Um 22.36 Uhr. Mit Mario Bartsch.
Im Fall Kurnatz sind fünf Angehörige des Bundeswehrkommandos Spezialkräfte streng abgeschirmt von der Öffentlichkeit vor dem Verteidigungsausschuss gehört worden. Sie sollten unter anderem die Zustände in einem US-Gefangenenlager in Kandahar in Afghanistan schildern, in dem Kurnatz Ende 2001 Anfang 2002 festgehalten wurde. Nach Angaben des in Bremen geborenen Türken wurde er dort auch von deutschen Soldaten misshandelt. Das Verteidigungsministerium weist diese Vorwürfe zurück. Der Absturz eines Stahlträgers von der Fassade des Berliner Hauptbahnhofs hätte nach Einschätzung des Architekten von Gerkan vermieden werden können. Von Gerkan sagte vor dem Verkehrsausschuss des Bundestages, er habe ursprünglich Haltevorrichtungen für die Träger geplant. Diese seien aber unter der Regie der Bahn bei der weiteren Bauausführung weggelassen worden. Bahnvorstandsmitglied Wieshoi wies jede Verantwortung zurück. Hotztowns Stadtverordnete haben im dritten Anlauf einem Landtagsneubau auf dem Areal des früheren Stadtschlosses zugestimmt. Es gab 29 Ja-Stimmen, 16 Ablehnungen und drei Enthaltungen. Zum Sport. In der Fußballbundesliga hat Hertha BSC auswärts gegen Hannover 96 0 zu 5 verloren. Energie Cottbus trennte sich vom Hamburger SV 1 zu 1. In den weiteren Mittwochspartien spielten Leverkusen gegen Bremen 0 zu 2, Mainz gegen Dortmund 1 zu 0 und Schalke gegen Aachen 2 zu 1. Der FC Bayern München hat Trainer Felix Magath gefeuert. Der Verein gab die Entscheidung am Nachmittag bekannt. Bis zum Saisonende wird der ehemalige Trainer Ottmar Hitzfeld die Bayern leiten. Auch Borussia München Gladbach braucht einen neuen Trainer. Jupp Heynckes erklärte am Mittag seinen Rücktritt. Und in der Basketballbundesliga hat Alba Berlin nach einer Heimniederlage gegen Spanien ins Basketball-Top-Team Real Madrid kaum noch Chancen auf einen Viertelfinaleinzug im Julepup. Die Berliner verloren das Achtelfinal-Hinspiel 65 zu vier Runden hittig. Heute Nacht kommen von Norden immer mehr Wolken zu uns und die bringen auch Regen mit. Die Tiefstwerte liegen bei 4 bis 2 Grad. Dazu ist es ziemlich windig. Am Tag dann meist sonnig und trocken bei Höchstwerten um die 8 Grad. A12 Berliner Ring Richtung Polen zwischen Frankfurt-Oder-Mitte und dem Grenzübergang staute sich und A113 Autobahnzubringer Dresden trebte Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Am Schönefelder Kreuz gab es einen Unfall, da die Ausfahrt zur A10 in Richtung Frankfurt-Oder betroffen ist. Wahrscheinlich noch offen.
Betroffen sind wir doch alle. Achso, du hast vergessen das Wort mit aufzuschreiben. Danke Mario, 22, 39.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 91, 9, dann fritzt rund um Belzig.
Als der Dude noch Musik gemacht hat.
Es gibt noch so Revolutionsklassiker.
Revolutionsklassiker.
Wir kommen da nicht drum herum.
Ja, aber ich finde die Nummer echt furchtbar. Das würde ich noch nicht mal mitgrölen, wenn ich besoffen wäre. Ich finde, man kann das auch sympathischer. Weißt du, so eingängiger. Meinst du, es ist zu kompliziert? Nee, ich finde das einfach so ein ganz fürchterliches Geschrammel.
Ja, über die Form. Die kaputten Lautsprecher wagen auf der Demo. Jetzt die Steine und die Moly.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich demnächst gesteinigt von irgendwelchen alten Revoluzzer, alten Revoluzzer.
Hast du auch schon den Film über die nette Dame aus der Kommune 1?
Nee, habe ich noch nicht verstanden. Werde ich mir auch nicht angucken. Weil ich scheiße auf Oboe. So, wir haben es vor den Nachrichten vollmutterlich angekündigt.
Horrorgeschichten aus den USA.
Na gut, das ist eher fast harmloser Horror. Aber für mich...
So macht das das Privatfernsehen auch. Vorher riesig, gleich geht es rund. Und dann ist es eigentlich gar nicht so.
Also ich hake es vielleicht mal ganz schnell ab. Das erste war, als bei der Einreise eine Firewire Festplatte von mir, von dem Beamten, der mein Gepäck kontrolliert hat, nicht erkannt wurde und als verdächtiger Gegenstand eingestuft. Das ist ein looking Device. Und er dann stand Firewire drauf und das klang irgendwie offenbar gefährlich. Und daraufhin hat er dann ein Formular darüber ausgefüllt, dass ich einen verdächtigen Gegenstand eingeführt habe, was ich dann anschließend unterzeichnen musste. So, da fühlt man sich dann schon mal erstmal ganz toll, wenn man so bei der Einreise erstmal begrüßt wird.
Und du hast noch nicht in der Live-Messe gesagt, Sir, this is a hard disk.
Das ging dann auch so ab, als ich dann einen Schritt auf ihn zutrat, weil er auch so schlecht zu verstehen war mit seinem Akzent, brüllte er mich erstmal nicht, sollte zurücktreten und hinter der Linie bleiben und außerdem dürfte ich mein Gepäck nicht anfassen, er kontrollierte da jetzt gerade. Also nicht so die Situation, wo man unbedingt jetzt zu Diskussionen neigt oder aufgelegt ist. Parallel eine Sache, eine Freundin, die zu zweit gereist sind und wo die dann zurückgeschickt wurde, weil ihre Freundin mit ihrem Pass und dem Flugticket schon mal vorausgegangen war und sie dann im Abfertigungsbereich ohne Papiere angetroffen wurde und daraufhin ja in den Flieger zurückgeschickt wurde. Ein anderer Kollege, der an einer amerikanischen Hochschule unterrichtet, saß acht Stunden im Immigration Bereich zusammen mit den illegalen Einwanderern, weil er gesagt hatte, dass er dort einen Vortrag an der Uni hält, aber keine Green Card hatte, die mit einer Arbeitsberechtigung erhält. Da hatte er auch große Mühe, überhaupt dort wieder rauszukommen. Der Gipfel war bei der Rückreise, wo ich fast möglicherweise auch auf die No-Flight-Liste gekommen wäre, weil ich in einen Passagieraufstand geraten bin, wo nach sechs Stunden Wartezeit und nicht besonders freundlicher Behandlung durch die Airline-Mitarbeiter, die Passagiere dann begannen, handgreiflich zu werden. Und ich, als dann halt eine Mutter mit ihrem Kind dann auch angegangen wurde, dort ich einfach auch mich nicht mehr zurückhalten konnte und mich dann auch eingemischt habe. Handgreiflich heißt, also es fing damit an, dass diese Frau jemanden auf die Schulter tippte von der Airline, der dort vorbeiging und keine Auskunft geben wollte, woraufhin dann die Mitarbeiterin dort einen Nervenzusammenbruch kriegte, in Tränen ausbrach und es hatten sich, also ich wollte es ja kurz halten, das würde zu weit sein.
Kannst du es mir irgendwo hinbloggen, vielleicht, dass man es lesen kann?
Ja, das ist genau das. Ich blogge es einfach mal irgendwo hin. Jedenfalls war dann die Situation, dass etwa 40 aufgebrachte Passagiere schreiend zehn Airline-Angestellten und zehn Sicherheitsleuten gegenüber standen und es kurz davor war. Zum Glück waren die Sicherheitsleute, die da waren, haben dann wirklich deeskalierend gewirkt und es hätte nur bedurft, dass einer von denen auch etwas aggressiver reagiert hätte und es wären einfach die Fetzen geflogen.
Woher kommt das, dass deine Firewire Festplatte nicht erkannt wird, dass du gezwungen wirst, ein Schreib zu unterzeichnen, auf dem steht, dass du nicht in den Gegenschein bist? Dummheit. Ist es Dummheit, aber nur dumme Menschen?
Ja, das ist da, also wer offenbar dort ein bisschen Bildung und Intelligenz hat, der ist dann Superweiser und der sitzt dann oben und zudem muss das erst mal raufeskaliert werden. Ansonsten, die normalen Leute, mit denen man es dann direkt zu tun hat, sind in der Regel Angelernte ohne Schulabschluss und Hilfspersonal. Und da ist auch die, die handeln ganz rigide wie Roboter. Da ist auch jedes Diskutieren völlig sinn- und zwecklos und sobald da eine Situation auftritt, die sie nicht handeln, wird es entweder hocheskaliert zur nächsten Stufe und bei der dritten Stufe ist man dann endlich bei jemandem angekommen, der auch denken darf.
So was hatte ich in Berlin, in Tegel am Flughafen. Als ich einchecken wollte, man hat mich nicht an den Check-In-Counter gelassen, ohne vorher meinen Personalausweis sich anzugucken. Ich hab noch nicht mal eingecheckt, wo du normalerweise deinen Personalausweis zeigst. Davor standen Leute in grauen Uniformen und wollten meinen Personalausweis sehen. Ich hab auch gefragt, warum. Ich hab gesagt, das würde meiner eigenen Sicherheit dienen. Auf die Frage, auf welche Weise das passiert, konnten sie mir keine Antwort geben, außer bitte gehen sie jetzt weiter. Das ist ähnlich. Und die Leute, die haben auch nicht gefragt. Ich stand einfach in der Schlange und verdammt noch mal, niemand kontrolliert meinen Personalausweis, wenn ich mich an einen Schalter begebe. Wo kommen wir denn dahin?
Ja, das ist vor allem kein privates Sicherheitspersonal.
Das war im Auftrag der Airline. Im Auftrag der AirBerlin ist das passiert. Und niemand hat mal gefragt, was soll der Schwachsinn eigentlich? Weil es ist ja auch Schwachsinn. Die kleben dann übrigens einen kleinen Aufkleber auf dein Perso. Dann gehst du zum Check-In, gibst da nochmal deinen Aufkleber ab. Da wird dann auch wirklich deine Identität überprüft. Weil das können die ja gar nicht. Das sind so 5-Euro-Pfeifen, die merken noch nicht, ob du einen gefälschten Person hast.
Wo ging denn der Flug hin?
Der ging nach Spanien.
Das ist ja sowieso schräg.
Das ist völlig lächerlich. Wenn du dann vom Check-In in den Sicherheitsbereich gehst, dann stehen ja nochmal diese Servicekräfte in Grau da und gucken dann deinen Personalausweis. Der Aufkleber auf dem Perse ist nur dazu da, dass die wissen, dass sie den schon mal gesehen haben. Ich hab den abgepiddelt. Weil ich hab nämlich das Mädel beim Check-In gefragt, wofür ist das eigentlich gut hier, dass sie das draufgegeben hat. Ich hab gesagt, nur damit die wissen, dass sie schon mal drauf geguckt haben. Und ich meinte, was passiert, wenn ich den abmache? Ja nix. Und die meinte, es ist sehr schön, dass das Personal von R-Berlin selber Schwachsinnig findet, was R-Berlin für Sachen macht. Dann hab ich den abgepittelt und dann werden die ganz nervös. Dann werden die immer richtig nervös.
Also das gleiche ist ja auch mit diesen Beuteln, die man jetzt haben muss, mit den Flüssigkeiten, Zahnpasta und so was. Also da steht es ja eigentlich auch an, dass die Leute im Prinzip quasi kleine Zettel in diese Beutel reintun, wo irgendwie klar sichtbar, lesbar drauf ist. Ich bin nicht einverstanden mit dieser Maßnahme, ich find's total scheiße, so überflüssig, das wissen sie auch. Und bitte sagen sie den Vorgesetzten, dass die Passagiere angenervt sind und da keinen Bock drauf haben.
Es ist wieder auch komplette Sicherheitssimulation, das bringt überhaupt gar nichts.
Niemand beschwert sich, also niemand sagt, was du sagst.
Doch, ich jedes Mal, wenn ich in der Schlange stehe, so ich erzähle jedem, wie scheiße ich das finde und wie schwachsinnig und wie überflüssig und wie sinnlos, dass den Kindern jetzt die Milch...
Da kann man ja an Bord kaufen für viel zu viel.
Ja, ganz bestimmt nicht. Also als ich gesehen hab, wie dort Kindernahrung von Babys einfach beschlagnahmt und in den Müll geworfen wurde, das ist die komplett wahnsinnige Hysterie einfach.
Vielleicht dann doch nicht mehr fliegen, merken sie es aber.
Das ist jetzt gerade dieser Widerstand im Kleinen, also dieses mit den anderen Reden und sagen sie finden es doch auch scheiße. Also ich denke, ja, das ist eigentlich auch beim Thema. Also was kann man eigentlich auch im Kleinen gegen machen?
Wo fällt es euch eigentlich auf, dass ihr gegängelt werdet und dass ihr in euren Freiheiten eingeschränkt werdet? 0331 70 97 1 0.
Maurice? Wo fällt es dir auf?
Also der Aufhänger war ja das, was auf dem Bildschirm stehen hast, wahrscheinlich mit dem Reisepass.
Bei mir steht zum Pass.
Also das war das erste halt. Wenn man nur eine kurze Anmerkung hat, man kann sich auch einen vorläufigen Reisepass ausstellen lassen, der hält dann zwar nur ein Jahr, aber es ist auch nur das biometrische Foto. Also keine Fingerabdrücke oder kein Chip oder sonst irgendwas. Ist auch ein bisschen kostenintensiv, aber okay, man muss ja jetzt nicht überall, immer in die USA reisen, und ansonsten tut es ja aus dem Personausweis. Das war das erste. Und dann habe ich mir mittlerweile mal einen kleinen Zettel gemacht von Bankerheim, das Telefonüberwachung, Videoüberwachung, E-Mail-Kontrolle oder was weiß ich, Banküberweisung. Kann alles überwacht werden.
Vorratsdaten, Speicherung, Online-Durchsuchung von PCs.
Genau. Und zum Beispiel in Frankfurt ist ja der E-Mail-Verteiler für ganz Deutschland, sprich jede E-Mail geht da durch, bevor sie auch weiter versenden, also nicht bevor sie weiter versendet wird.
Kann man das jemand mal erklären? Erkläre es mir, wie man es einem Kind erklärt.
Den DZIX ist sozusagen ein zentraler oder ein sehr wichtiger Internetknoten. Und da kann man davon ausgehen, dass viele E-Mails da auch vorbeikommen, ja.
Genau. Und das Bankerheimnis beispielsweise, das geht halt niemandem was an, wie viel oder was ich halt auf dem Konto habe. Und wenn man dann unbedingt an meinen Aktien und Umsätzen partizipieren will, dann kann man ja eine Art Quellensteuer einführen, was dann ganz legitim ist. Sprich, es ist halt wie eine Umsatzsteuer. Ich besteuere das, wenn ich einen Umsatz tätige und nicht mein Gewinn oder sonst irgendwie was, was ich... Das ist völlig außen vor. Und dann füge mir noch einen, gerade mit Terror, weil ihr das jetzt besprochen habt mit den Airlines und so weiter. Es gibt halt Sachen, wo Panik gemacht wird, gerade auch so von den Medien und natürlich auch von Staatskriegen, um einfach auch Freiheitsrechte abzuschaffen. Also, wenn ich mich daran erinnere, mit der Vogelgrippe zum Beispiel, was ja...
Schönes Beispiel, ja.
Für die ganz Doofen und alle sind sie drauf reingefallen, ja.
Ja, ich meine, man hätte dazu genötig oder gezwungen werden können, eine Impfung bei sich zu machen. Und ich meine, das ist dem wenigsten bewusst gewesen. Und da wäre praktisch der Notstand ausgerufen worden, ja. Und ich hätte mich nicht dagegen wehren können, oder ich wäre halt verhaftet worden.
Hast du eine Theorie oder eine Antwort auf die Frage, warum unsere Innenminister das überhaupt machen? Weil das, ich verstehe das nicht, die können doch nicht so, also, ja.
Tja, warum man das macht, gute Frage. Danke. Der gläserne Mensch, also, also es sind dann auch noch so andere Kleinigkeiten, wenn man jetzt beim Fußball ist oder so, wo man dann irgendwann in einer Datei auftaucht, Gewalttäter Sport, und man dann irgendwie durch Dufer mal ein Länderspiel ist, wo man ausreisen möchte, weil man aber gar nicht an dem Spiel teilnehmen will, sondern halt wirklich ins Ausland will, und da wird man dann eine Ausreise kindert, weil man irgendwann mal aufgenommen wurde und man steht jetzt bei einer Polizeidatei drin, oder auch ein anderes Beispiel, wenn jetzt irgendwie ein Sähenmörder umgeht und man macht einen Speicheltest, die Daten, die werden ja nicht weggeschmissen.
Naja, wer dahin geht, ist aber auch selber schuld.
Ja, natürlich, man kann ja sagen.
Es wird aber auch genug Angst gemacht, also die Schreibung ist ja schon so formuliert, und zur Not holen wir sie dann auch vom Arbeitsplatz ab. Also es ist ja auch so, dass sie...
Echt, das schreiben die da?
Ich mein, wenn man einmal in der Datei ist, dann ist man in der Datei. Und wenn irgendwas, dann kann auch diese Daten zurückgegriffen werden.
Ich mein, das ist eigentlich eine ganz interessante Frage, um das mal aufzugreifen. Was ja gerade an diesen DNA-Tests man auch sehen kann, ist halt diese verstörende Tendenz in der Bevölkerung, sich wirklich auch freiwillig dazu bereit zu erklären, bei solchen Sachen mitzumachen.
Also einen freiwilligen Generalverdacht über sich zu machen.
Ja, also einfach auch diese Bürgerrechte irgendwie freiwillig darauf zu verzichten und diesen Sicherheitswahn mitzumachen oder irgendwie helfen zu wollen und dabei gar nicht im Kopf zu haben, was da eigentlich alles an Konsequenzen damit schwingt.
Eben. Also ich find das auch sau dumm von vielen Menschen, ja ich hab mir ja nichts vorzuwerfen oder so Video überwachen oder so.
Wer nichts zu verbergen hat, der muss auch nichts befürchten. Das ist das, was solche Leute wie Jörg Schönbohm oder Wolfgang Schäuble erzählen.
Ich find das einfach sau dumm.
Ja klar, aber es funktioniert. Warum funktioniert es? Oder beziehungsweise wie kriegen wir es hin, dass es nicht mehr funktioniert? Wie kriegen wir hin, dass sich nicht irgendwelche stockkonservativen, ängstlichen Politiker hinstellen können und sagen, wenn sie nichts zu verbergen haben, haben sie ja nichts zu befürchten. Wie kriegen wir es hin, dass selbst die Privatfernsehgucker begreifen, dass das Quatsch ist, was sie da erzählen?
Na wir haben vielleicht eine Sache. Noch mal eine Frage. Du hast schon so ein biometrisches Bild. Hast du einen Pass oder einen Ausweis mit einem biometrischen Bild?
Ja, leider Gottes vor anderthalb Jahren verpasst mir, einen neuen Reihenpass machen zu lassen für zehn Jahre.
Wie siehst denn du aus auf dem Bild? Wie gefällst du dir? Ich frage, weil ich sehe aus wie ein Schwerverbrecher auf dem Bild. Man darf ja nicht lächeln. Man darf nicht lächeln. Das heißt, es sieht einfach aus schon mal wie ein Fahndungsbild, wie so ein Polizeifoto, wo man grimmig in die Kamera guckt und einfach unfreundlich und unsympathisch aussieht.
Das stimmt, aber ich konnte mir ein gewisses Lächeln nicht verkneifen. Das ging dann auch ruhig.
Okay, dann hast du noch Glück. Man sollte es vielleicht wirklich mit lächeln. Das fand ich so richtig furchtbar. Jedes Mal, wenn ich jetzt meinen Pass vorzeige, denke ich, dass die mich irgendwie gleich allein nur wegen des Bildes schon nicht durchlassen.
Das liegt daran, dass du paranoid bist.
Ich fand es ja gut, wo einer durchgesetzt hat, dass er mit ausgestreckter Zunge auf dem Passfoto abgebildet sein darf.
Wie hat er das durchgesetzt?
Ja, vor Gericht. Er machte es immer so, das ist so sein Merkmal.
Paranoia fällt mir noch ein. Paranoia ist nur ein anderes Wort für übertriebene Wachsamkeit. Und ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht.
Das wird Jörg Schönbohm auch sagen. Das ist auch nur einfach erhöhte Wachsamkeit, dass wir hier so ein riesiges Polizeigesetz in Brandenburg durchgeprügelt haben.
Ja, aber meine Paranoia ist, dass mir das genau auffällt.
Ich habe bei vielen Leuten gehört, die jetzt bei dem bei dem biometrischen Bild auch schon nicht begeistert waren. Also gerade Frauen sind natürlich nicht begeistert, vor allem wie sie dann auf den neuen Bildern aussehen. Aber bei den Fingerabdrücken habe ich von vielen gehört. Jetzt ist aber Schluss. Und so eine Aktion, zu der wir aufrufen wollten, war doch Politiker-Fingerabdrücke zu sammeln. Also es ist ja oft so die Situation, dass man irgendwo vielleicht speziell in Berlin zusammen mit irgendeinem Politiker im Lokal ist und das Glas, was der dann benutzt hat, das kann man dann einfach mitnehmen. Und wir würden dann halt die ganzen Fingerabdrücke online stellen. Die Anleitung, wie man sich die ausdrucken kann, die gibt es ja schon, wie man dann eben entsprechend sich die Abdrücke auf die eigenen Fingerkuppen montieren kann, sodass man dann halt, ja, sich aussuchen kann, ob ich heute halt die Fingerabdrücke von Herrn Schäuble oder von wem auch immer gerne hinterlasse, wo ich überall unterwegs bin.
Kann man die dann eigentlich auch nehmen, um seinen eigenen Reisepass dann damit zu bestücken?
Mit ein bisschen Übung geht das bestimmt, ja.
Das wäre doch schön, wenn alle die Fingerabdrücke von Schäuble haben.
Und das Foto von Schäuble im Pass.
Also wer uns da draußen hört, also die Anleitung, wie man die Abdrücke abnimmt und uns dann zusenden kann, findet ihr dann demnächst.
Also zur Not auch einfach das Glas gut einpacken, vorsichtig und Karton.
Ja wieso, da gibt es auch Spionagekasten im Kinderbildspielzeugladen. Wie heißt denn die? Geheimagentenset.
Also auch wenn ihr natürlich sonst irgendwie die Fingerabdrücke bekommen habt, so muss jetzt nicht speziell von einem Glas sein, sondern wenn ihr irgendwie an die Fingerabdrücke von Politikern rangekommen seid, bei uns sind sie in guter Hand.
Politikerfingerabdrücke sind eine tolle Idee.
Also wir müssen die sowieso viel mehr kontrollieren. Das sind ja potentiell kriminelle alles. Und wir brauchen viel mehr Maßnahmen zur Gefahrenabwehr bei Politikern. Ich meine, die ganzen Korruptionsskandale, alles.
Und die Problempolitiker, genau. Bruno, der Problempolitiker. Maurice, einstweilen, schönen Dank.
Tschüss.
Chaosradio 120 ist hier. Ziviler Ungehorsam für Anfänger. Politikerfingerabdrücke sammeln war eine so eine Idee, die wir gerade hatten. Chaosradio 120, Ziviler Ungehorsam für Anfänger. War das ein Anfänger? Ja, Anfänger. Neben Politiker Fingerabdrücken haben wir uns noch überlegt, Politiker Urin zu sammeln. Dabei werden uns die Kollegen von Akte, von ÖSERPROZIM, nee, ZAD 1, dabei werden die uns sicherlich helfen, die lungern sowieso den ganzen Tag auf dem Bundestagsklorum, um Wischproben zu nehmen. Was machen sie hier? Wir nehmen Wischproben. Gut, weitermachen.
Sperma-Proben hätten wir uns auch gern.
Das machen die Praktikanten dann. 033177110, Ziviler Ungehorsam für Anfänger. Was unternehmen wir denn am besten dagegen, was wir uns eigentlich alles gefallen lassen? So ein blödscheuerter Satz auch. Ich geh mal ans Telefon bei Manuel. Woran merkst du, dass du gegängelt wirst?
Ja, allein schon, dass ich die EC-Karte in Zigarettenautomaten reinstecken muss. Weil ich weiß ja nicht, was da irgendwie mitgelockt wird oder wer die Daten kriegt, wenn welche da sind.
Na deine Krankenversicherung. Na was meinst du, wer Interesse daran hat zu wissen, wer sich dann alles so eine EC-Karte mit diesem Altersmerkmal geholt hat?
Naja, das Altersmerkmal ist ja erst super als drauf, wenn ich über 18 bin.
Ja, aber du musst ja die Karte speziell anfordern. Also selbst wenn es ja automat nicht mitlockt. Deine Bank weiß natürlich, da kann sich natürlich schon ein Reim drauf machen, wer jetzt Raucher ist und wer nicht von den Kunden. Das meint sowohl wer Anfang Januar alles bei den Banken gestanden hat.
Das riecht man aber auch, wer Raucher ist und wer nicht.
Ja, auf meiner EC-Karte war der Geldkartenchip sowieso drauf. Und finde ich äußerst beruhigend. Ich meine, die Jungs, die die Automaten auffinden, werden auch nicht 10 Euro die Stunde verdienen.
Achso, du meinst... Oh, der scheint was Wahres gesagt zu haben und ihm ist die Leitung getrennt worden oder sowas. Aber es ist natürlich auch ein interessanter Punkt, einfach so schlecht bezahlte Mitarbeiter zu kaufen von solchen Firmen.
Das funktioniert bei Callcentern wunderbar. Wenn du überlegst, was ein Callcenter-Mitarbeiter, was der alles für Daten sammeln kann, dann ist es ja so, dass Callcenter in der Regel nicht nur, also die arbeiten ja nicht für eine Branche, also jetzt für alle Mobilfunkunternehmer, sondern es ist so, dass die immer so ein ziemlich breites Feld haben, aber dafür keine Konkurrenz. Das heißt, die arbeiten für eine Bank, für eine Versicherung, für eine Telefonfirma und für einen... und die Chance, dass irgendwie tatsächlich mal alles oder viel davon auf dich zutrifft und diese eine Person wirklich auch in alle deine Datensätze reingucken kann, ist relativ groß.
In Indien haben ja mehrere Firmen schon ein alternatives Geschäftsmodell noch aufgemacht und halt die persönlichen Daten von Leuten in den USA dann an entsprechende russische Gruppen weitergeleitet, die dann halt mit den entsprechenden Kreditkartendaten oder deren Identitäten dann entsprechend Geschäfte getätigt haben.
Getreu nach dem Motto, was ist besser als eine Bank zu überfallen, ist eine Bank zu eröffnen.
Offensichtlich. Manuel ist rausgeflogen, dann gehen wir mal.
Grüß dich.
Und was fällt dir so auf?
Ich wollte erst mal den Moderator Steinigen dafür wegen Tonsteine scherben. Ich bin etwas älterer, dass er so Kampflied schlechtieren. Es ist aber trotzdem schlecht musiziert.
Zumindest nicht mehr zeitgemäß musiziert, oder?
Ja, Gott, aber wenn ich das Zeug höre, was manchmal vom Plattenteller kommt heute, dann ist das ja auch schon ganz schön.
Wenn es wenigstens vom Plattenteller käme. Ich fühle mich auf jeden Fall gesteinigt. Jetzt zum Thema zurück.
Ich gehöre hier eben zum älteren Semester und war aktiv im After-Meiner-Uni zu der Zeit, dass die Volkszählung kam.
Das war 1983, war das?
Lang her, genau. 1983 kam der Urteil dann. Also wir hatten eine riesige Maschinerie aufgebaut gehabt, wo wir eben Leute geradezu Ziviler Ungehorsam aufrufen wollten, wenn uns sozusagen der Bundesverfassungsgericht einen Strich durch die Rechnung gemacht hat, in den sie von selbst auf die Idee gekommen ist, dass das keine so gute Idee gewesen sei.
Aber die ist ja trotzdem durchgeführt worden.
Ja, die haben es aber ein bisschen abgewandelt gehabt dazu. Also das, was die großen Probleme dabei waren. Also die Bögen waren ja nummeriert. Die Volkszählung ist selber nicht gemacht worden, sondern die, da ist eine, wie hieß es denn? Also es war ja nicht eine Volkszählung. Sie haben nur eine Mikro-Zensus nannte sich das genau.
Nein, die Volkszählung ist auch schon gemacht worden. Also ich kann mich dran erinnern, dass da mal Zähler rumkamen und auch Bögen abgegeben haben. Die ist schon gemacht worden, aber es sind halt sehr enge Grenzen gesetzt worden.
Sehr, sehr enge Grenzen gesetzt worden. Also ich meine, ich hab inzwischen eine Volkszählung anderswo auch gesehen gehabt. Also ich sammle Volkszählungsbögen nur so ein bisschen ab.
Interessant, das ist Hobby.
Ich sammle vieles. Aber es ist ja so gewesen, also ich war damals relativ aktiv und fand das sehr lustig, dass ich dann plötzlich ganz zisferlich für die Mikro-Census gewählt gewesen bin. Und da haben wir, also da passiert mir so viele dobe Sachen irgendwie, also diese blöde Bogen, weißt du, das war, ach da hat der Hund das gegessen und dann muss ich immer wieder neuen anfordern. Und dann hätte ich es endlich mal geschafft, das Ding auszufüllen und hab's in Briefkassen geworfen und ausgerechnet am Silvester. Und da wurde ja der Kasten gespringt, weil jemand ein Feuerwerk da reingeschmissen hat. Und ich hab die Artikel rausgeschnitten auf der Zeitung und denen hingeschickt. Und dann haben sie aufgehört, mir Bögen zu schicken.
Hättest du es nicht einfach verweigern können, das auszufüllen?
Mikro-Census nicht.
Da ist man zu verpflichtet. Das geht überhaupt nicht.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich es nicht ausfülle? Nehmt ihr mir einen Beugerhaft oder was?
Ich mein, aber es gibt noch was viel Nettos, was man einfach machen kann. Gerade mit diesen ganzen Umfragen und so, die alles mal rumkommen. Füll sie mal aus, gib tolle Daten dazu, damit man auch die Datenbanken korrumpieren kann dabei. Ich bin Informatikerin und ich weiß, man macht gerne der BD-Mining mit diesen ganzen Daten. Gib die Futter.
Das war eine Freundin von mir, die hatte so einen GFK-Scanner, wo sie dann gescannt hat, was für Sachen sie kaufen. Da haben wir uns dann auch irgendwie beküft den Spaß draus gemacht.
Es gibt irgendjemanden auf dem Spielplatz, die mindeln mit oder so. Solche Sachen, um die Leute zu irritieren. Ich bestell auch bei Amazon für die ganze Familie und amusiere mich köstlich über die Vorschläge, die ich sehe von Amazon, was ich mir jetzt als Next-es kaufen soll.
Das ist so die Idee von dieser Privacy-Card, die der Führburt in Bielefeld mal gemacht hat. Die haben eine Payback-Karte geklont, irgendwie 1500 Mal. Und dann gab es 1500 Leute, die mit dieser einen Karte rumgegangen sind. Ich meine, Scheiß auf die Punkte. Aber das Kaufprofil war bestimmt auch ganz lustig davon. Das fanden sie auch gar nicht gut.
Aber ich meine, sowas kann man ja einfach identifizieren und ausschließen. Aber diese kleinen Änderungen, also allen Fragebögen, was man irgendwie in die Finger kriegen kann und dann richtig schick ausfüllen, also immer so ein bisschen daneben.
Ein kleiner netter Tipp ist noch, manchmal, also erstmal hatten wir das auch auf unserer Liste noch, nämlich Data Mining sabotieren. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein guter Ansatz, Sand ins Getriebe zu streuen, indem man einfach schlechte Daten nimmt. Nett ist auch, wenn man mal irgendwo doch richtige Daten angeben muss, weil man ja irgendwie Post zurück erwartet oder braucht, ist es ganz nett als mittleren Namen den Namen der Firma in umgekehrter Reihenfolge einzusetzen.
Oder in Buchstabenabkürzung oder sowas.
Dann weiß man wenigstens, wo die Daten herkommen. Das rechnen die nicht raus? Das funktioniert wunderbar. Ich lach mich immer kaputt, wenn ich Post kriege und dort mit wirklich den absurdesten Mittelnamen dann...
Da muss man gut buchführen, damit man nachvollziehen kann, wo das euch herkommt.
Das Nette ist, wenn man den Firmennamen einfach in die Mitte Buchstaben umgedreht reinschreiben. Das fällt keinem auf. Das fällt keinem auf.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde das fast ein bisschen feige. Das ist eine Form des Weichenprotests, was auch damals viele bei der Volksdelegation gemacht haben. Die haben gesagt, sie tragen etwas Unplausibles ein. Aber das Problem ist, das hat ja keine Außenwirkung. Da denken halt alles ist okay und die Leute machen brav mit. Die merken vielleicht, es ist ein Prozentsatz, zwei Prozent, die da mitmachen, das wird rausgerechnet als Rauschen. Aber es gibt nicht wirklich... Dann festigen sich auch, weil niemand was beschwert. Ich trag da ein bisschen was Falsches ein und... Das wird schon irgendwie alles... Und an sich wär's doch besser, wenigstens da laut aufzuschreien.
Deswegen war der Weg zur Bundesverfassungsgerichtung genau der richtige. Was mich im Moment sehr beunruhigt, ist damals festgestellt worden, es ist nicht erlaubt, die deutsche Bevölkerung durchzunummerieren.
Wird jetzt aber trotzdem gemacht?
Ja, genau. Im Sommer steht das jetzt so an. Das haben sie vor, noch Personalnummern durchzusetzen. Ich komme ursprünglich aus dem USA, hab dort auch ein Personalnummer, diese elendige Social Security-Nummer, die für alles benutzt wird. Und es gibt immer wieder Probleme, wenn man diesen Nummer nicht hat. Die gehen immer davon aus, alle Leute haben diesen Nummer.
Oder man gibt eine andere irgendwo an.
Ja, aber auch Leute, die nur zu Besuch sind, oder Gastarbeiter sind, oder eben Illegalen, die hier sind, die haben so eine Nummer nicht. Und werden die absurdesten Sachen teilweise verweigert, weil sie die Nummer nicht haben. In Skandinavien ist es ja auch üblich, dass es so eine Personennummer gibt. Und ohne so eine Nummer bist du kein Mensch. Also du kannst ja nicht mal so eine Paybackkarte kriegen, wenn du diese Nummer nicht hast. Weil die wird ja überall auf dem Schuss übernommen.
Du kannst ja kein Telefon anmelden, keine Gans. Eine Freundin von mir ist ausgewandert. Und das hat ewig gedauert, bis sie ihr endlich diese Nummer zugewiesen haben.
Und ohne diese Nummer. Nichts. Und es sind absurd die trivialsten Sachen, wo man sagt, also hallo, ich will hier nur eine Parkkarte, damit ich hier ein paar in eure Parkhaus parken kann. Hier, nee, ohne Personennummer kannst du es nicht machen.
Das wird dann hier wohl auch irgendwann die Folge sein.
Das wird auch hier die Folge sein. Nur damals ist festgestellt worden, dass wir die deutsche Bevölkerung nicht durchnummerieren dürfen, weil sie im Dritten Reich ja versucht haben, die Juden durchzunummerieren und auch drauf tatuiert haben die Nummern. Wo ist das geblieben? Warum schreit keiner mehr drüber nach?
Es gibt auch, deswegen gibt es ja auch in Deutschland oder gab es bisher ein dezentrales Meldewesen. Das heißt also keine zentrale Datenbank aller Einwohner. Und auch das ist jetzt auf dem Weg abzuschaffen.
Wird da denn jemand gegen klagen? Also ich meine, oder wird es hier um...
Klar, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber wer wird es tun?
Ja, da gibt es auch viele Organisationen, mit denen der CCC zusammen ist. Teilweise auch einige Parteien werden wahrscheinlich... Also die Opposition wird wahrscheinlich auch klagen. Aber es gibt...
Wir haben auch damals zu den biometrischen Pässen ja gesagt. Das ist auch nichts, worauf man sich jetzt verlassen kann.
So ein Problem, was bei dieser ganzen Sache auch wieder im Hintergrund steckt, was wir vorhin auch schon hatten, ist überhaupt erst mal diese Problembewusstsein in der Öffentlichkeit für diese Thematik hinzukriegen. Wenn man jetzt z.B. Data Miner sabotiert, was man ja persönlich so im Kleinen gerne machen kann. Aber wenn man halt eben so einer von diesen 2% ist und 98% machen das mit, weil sie es super finden, wenn irgendwie die Spaghetti neben der Soße stehen, weil das irgendwie bei Paybackkarten dann rausgefunden wird, dann kommt man einfach nicht weit mit diesem kleinen Rahmen von zivilen Widerstand.
Man muss ja eher die Leute aufschrecken, indem man sie zeigt, was alles für Daten man über sie rauskriegen kann.
Das Problem ist doch viel eher, dass du überhaupt keine Möglichkeit hast, den Leuten klarzumachen oder eindrucksvoll und knapp klarzumachen, was das Problem daran ist, eine zentrale Datei mit zentralen Nummern, also eine zentrale Datei mit eindeutigen Nummern für jeden Bundesbürger anzulegen. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, den Menschen zu sagen, das ist ein Problem, weil. Das Einzige, was du machen kannst, ist, guck ins Dritte Reich sagen und in dem Moment, wo du mit einem Dritte Reich Vergleich kommst, diskalifizierst du dich eigentlich schon, weil jeder sagt, komm jetzt kein Nazi-Vergleich.
Ja, aber das ist ein ganz großes Problem, finde ich, auch bei ganz vielen Datenschutzthemen und überhaupt bei ganz vielen technikaktivistischen Themen, dass man eigentlich im Grunde die ganze Zeit gegen so ein Worst-Case-Szenario argumentiert. Man muss im Grunde genommen den Leuten immer wieder sagen, stell dir mal vor, was Adolf Hitler machen würde, wenn der diese Mittel zur Verfügung hätte. Aber dadurch, dass es einfach nicht so präsent ist und das es auch keiner als akutes Problem ansieht in der gegenwärtigen Situation, fehlt da einfach so ein Bewusstsein dafür, das jetzt auch wirklich als drängenderes Problem wahrzunehmen.
Wie der Frosch im kalten Wasser. Solange das nur langsam erwärmt wird. Man merkt es nicht, die springen ja nicht raus.
Aber was ist denn das andere Argument, wenn wir nicht Adolf Hitler nehmen? Was wäre das nächste Gelegenheit? Aber Werte verstehen die Leute nicht. Bei jemandem, der sich Big Brother anguckt, versteht nicht, was Würde ist.
Genau. Und die verstehen nicht den Unterschied zwischen Google und Internet. Deswegen haben wir so große Schwierigkeiten, ihnen überhaupt zu erklären, was treiben wir eigentlich mit Computer? Der Computer ist so ein komischer Wesen. Der muss auch demystifiziert werden. Aber das ist ja schon der erste Grundschritt, die eigentlich passieren sollte, bevor wir überhaupt in der Lage sind, den Leuten klar zu machen, was der böse Computer anstellen kann. Nämlich die Leute, die das benutzen können, können relativ schnell solche Sachen berechnen. Also ich bin sehr pessimistisch geworden in den letzten Jahrzehnten.
Ja, aber das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Aufklärung ist eine ganz, ganz große Sache. Und Aufklärung muss auch meiner Meinung nach auf einer ganz breiten Basis passieren. Man muss nicht einfach nur aufklären, was im Einzelnen jetzt mit so einer einzelnen technischen Maßnahme passieren kann, sondern auch ganz allgemein breit darüber aufklären, was allgemein passieren kann, wenn jetzt politische Maßnahmen technisch gestützt werden oder was das auch in der Geschichte immer für Konsequenzen hatte, wenn Technologien eingeführt wurden, die wurden nämlich nie wieder abgeschafft, sondern immer nur wieder ein bisschen variiert und verwandelt. Und dann mal so ein allgemeines Problembewusstsein überhaupt dafür hinzukriegen, dass die Leute eben auch auf technische Maßnahmen sehen, die irgendwie in die Bevölkerung oder in politische Prozesse eingebettet werden. Was da eigentlich dahinter steht und wie die Politik verändern, wie die Rechte verändern und all solche Sachen. Das ist irgendwie sowas, was total diffus ist. Und natürlich auch von denjenigen, die das umsetzen, tunlichst Terminen wird, dass da irgendwie dann ein Klartext gesprochen wird.
Verstehen die es überhaupt?
Im großen Teil eben nicht. Das ist auch noch so ein interessantes Ding, wenn man dann...
Die Politiker verstehen das auch nicht. Ich nehme das als meinen Auftrag an, da ich Informatikerin bin, zu versuchen, allen möglichen Leuten klar zu machen, einen besonderen Politiker klar zu machen. Was hat das für Auswirkungen? Nein, natürlich nicht. Also gelegentlich, weil ich ja auch noch ein paar Buchstaben von meinem Namen her schiebe. Aber Sie wollen es nicht hören. Es stört den irgendwie. Ach, das ist so kompliziert. Bleiben Sie mir davon weg.
Also es geht aber zum Teil. Ich habe auch gerade über diese Geschichte letztens mit Kollegen von der Technik-Folgenabschätzung gesprochen. Und die sitzen ja ein bisschen näher dran. Die haben ja Kontakt zu den Bundestagsabgeordneten, sprechen mit denen und legen ihnen auch Berichte vor über Technik und wie sich Technik entwickeln kann. Und die haben mir erzählt, dass sie die Erfahrung hatten, dass sich die Politiker in dem Moment wirklich dafür interessiert haben. Und dann in dem Moment auch erst gesehen haben, was da überhaupt passieren kann. Und dann auch ein erhöhtes Problembewusstsein in diesen Sachen gegenüber hatten.
Doch groß angelegte Politiker-Informationskampagnen machen, wäre das eine Möglichkeit?
Kampagnen, vielleicht eher Aktionen. Also wir haben, wie sagt man jetzt, Cottbus, was wir eingangs der Sendung haben, ist vielleicht ein gutes Beispiel für etwas, wo mal was gelungen ist. Und das war eine Kombination aus Dingen. Am Anfang stand halt der Niederpack, wo einfach ein ganz einfaches, plakatives Ereignis da war, was für Wellen gesorgt hat.
Das versteht auch jeder Schach auf einem Wahlcomputer.
Und Wahlbetrug. Also das war einfach genug, als es es auch in die Presse geschafft hat. Und dann eben nicht locker lassen und das Ganze begleiten und immer wieder draufhauen und lästig werden. Und das scheint zumindest Teilerfolge jetzt gebracht zu haben. Das hat uns auch ermuntert, jetzt auf dem Weg eigentlich weiterzumachen. Das heißt, weitere spektakuläre Aktionen zu überlegen, die man dann entsprechend dann versucht, politisch dann in entsprechende Bahnen zu lenken.
Wobei mir, also mir persönlich sind da viele Sachen. Ich finde, man kann eigentlich so, was ja die Gegenseite so zusammen macht, diese technischen Möglichkeiten voll auszureizen in vielen Fällen. Es gibt natürlich immer die richtigen Einschränkungen. Ich denke mal zum Beispiel der CIA in den USA, die machen einfach prinzipiell alles, was technisch möglich ist. Und ich finde, dass man auf der technikaktivistischen Seite eigentlich auch mal viel mehr, viel mehr sich raus wagen müsste in diese Bereiche, das technisch Mögliche überhaupt. Also was ich zum Beispiel super fände, ich will jetzt nicht zu aufrufen, dann will ich hier bestimmt...
Du sagst jetzt zum Beispiel.
Hypothetisch gesehen, wäre zum Beispiel mal von allen Bundestagsabgeordneten die private Kommunikation, E-Mail, Handy, alles mal versuchen rauszukriegen und zu finden. Oder auch die ganzen Bankinformationen, Bankbewegungen, wie viel Konten überhaupt haben, was da alles gezeigt wird. Was die Überwähler erzählen, so untereinander und das einfach mal alles freizulegen und mal denen zu zeigen, was...
Ich höre mich nicht mal, wenn man denen vorspielt, was sie gesagt haben letztes Jahr.
Naja, aber ich meine, um denen mal zu zeigen, was sie da eigentlich eingeführt haben. Also ich meine, das, was wir jetzt haben, sind ja sozusagen die dezenten Anfänge von dem, was dann letzten Endes, wenn jetzt ein Diktator dran käme oder sowas, was dann ohne weiteres mit mit ein, zwei Schaltern umgelegt möglich wäre. Und wenn man denen dann zeigt, was sie da für ein Potenzial in die Welt gesetzt haben.
Ich meine, grundsätzlich wäre das natürlich schon ein Verstoß gegen die Herkerethik. Es sei denn, so, man erklärt jetzt einfach, ja, spricht Politiker in ihre Privatsphäre ab, sagt, okay, weil sie Politiker sind und sich dort hineinbegeben haben, oder weil sie, ich sag mal, gegen die Privatsphäre agieren, verwirken sie das Recht auf eigene Privatsphäre?
Wie wässt denn, wenn du das nicht in einem illegalen Bereich machst, sondern einen Politiker suchst, der vielleicht einigermaßen integer ist, nehmen wir Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg, Hans-Christian Ströbele, der tut immer so, als wäre er ganz weit vorne dabei und ganz progressiv, dass man einfach mal sagt, so Herr Ströbele, jetzt machen wir das mal exemplarisch an Ihnen. Wir schwerzen die Zahlen, die hinten rausfallen, wenn wir auf Ihr Konto gucken, aber wir gucken jetzt mal auf Ihr Konto und dieses Ding, dieses Ergebnis veröffentlichen wir dann mit einem riesigen Medien-Tamm-Tamm. Das wäre ja eine Möglichkeit, wo wir praktisch aus beiden Bereichen das Gute nehmen können. Du bist nicht illegal und du hast trotzdem den Plakatien.
Man muss ja nicht so weit gehen, um Hans Christian da seinen Kontoauszüge zu nehmen, sondern es kann ein bisschen anders gehen, dass man sagt, ich schreibe jetzt ein Szenario oder mehrere, wo ich also ziemlich genau und detailliert so eine Situation begebe. Ich habe nichts zu verbergen und plötzlich sind eben die Daten so verknüpft.
Es geht ja nicht um das Szenario selbst, sondern es muss ja diejenigen treffen, die betroffen sind. Und wenn du dich jetzt hinsetzt und sagst, ich schreibe jetzt ein Szenario und das zeige ich dann einem Politiker, dann sagt der Politiker, ja, aber dazu wird es nicht kommen, da sind ja die Gesetze davor. Wenn Ströbel aber sagt, ich verzichte hiermit einfach mal darauf, euch zu verklagen, wenn ihr die Nummer durchzieht. Und dann ziehst du die Nummer mal durch und dann sehen eben alle, was passieren kann.
Ich denke mal, dass Ströbel vielleicht genau der Falsche dafür.
Nein, aber Ströbel wäre jemand, dem ich zumindest von dem, was ich von ihm so mitbekomme, zutrauen würde, dass er sagt, ich verzichte darauf, euch zu verklagen.
Ja, gut. Möglicherweise, ja. Wobei andererseits muss ja auch klar sein, das ist ja eben schon illegal. Wir wollen ja auch, dass es illegal ist.
Ja, natürlich. Aber es ist eben nicht für alle illegal.
Es ist eben die Frage, ob man sich nicht überhaupt als Aktivist auch gerade in diesem Bereich der Illegalität auch mal bewusst begeben sollte.
Da hab ich Probleme mit. Ich hab Probleme damit, Illegales zu machen. Aber man kann ja manchmal das, was an die Legalität einfach so ein bisschen biegen und ein bisschen anders mal schauen, um das gegen jemanden verwenden zu können. Nur also in so was Illegales hineinzugehen. Da hatte ich große Hemmungen.
Das Problem ist nur, dass du nicht weißt, wann das, was du biegst, gebrochen wird. Das liegt immer noch im Ermessen eines Gerichts, zu sagen, das war jetzt wirklich illegal oder das war es nicht.
Ich meine, man hat natürlich mit so etwas größer als aktivistischer Perspektive natürlich mit so etwas größeren und fundamentaleren illegalen Aktionen zwei Vorteile, also besonders, wenn die sich an so Maßnahmen richten, die ja eigentlich illegitime Interessen umsetzen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die ja gegen Unschuldsvermutung und Verhältnismäßigkeit verstößt, was ja auch fundamentale Bestandteile unserer Verfassung sind. Und dann hat man natürlich den Vorteil, dass zum einen man viel stärker in eine öffentliche Diskussion kommt. Man hat eine viel bessere öffentliche Präsenz, wenn man sich mit diesen Medienmodalitäten ansieht, wie man da reinkommt. Da hat man natürlich dann, wenn man was Illegales macht und was riskiert dafür, um jetzt nochmal was Bestimmtes zu zeigen, eine viel bessere Präsenz. Und man hat natürlich als zweites auch den Vorteil, dass man mit so einer legalen und rechtlichen Auseinandersetzung eigentlich auch diese Halblegalitäten, die so ein bisschen gemauschelt unter den Tisch immer vollzogen werden, auch mal in so einen rechtlichen Diskurs reinzieht. Also man hat natürlich dann im Moment, in dem man sozusagen illegal gegen illegale Mittel vorgeht, hat man natürlich dann eine rechtliche Diskussion um die Rechtmäßigkeit dieses Vorgehens. Und in diesem Rahmen kann man dann natürlich auch schön mit rechtlichen Instanzen darüber diskutieren, inwiefern überhaupt die Maßnahmen an sich sind.
Dass es hieß, dass es illegal war, Links zu setzen auf illegalem Inhalt.
Nee, aber es gibt einfach Sachen, die ganz klar einfach auch gegen Sätze verstoßen, wie zum Beispiel die Weitergabe von Flugpassagierdaten. Oder auch so Sachen möglicherweise, die... Das ist gerechtlich noch nicht entschieden, aber es sprechen einige Anzeichen dagegen, zum Beispiel die Kreditkartengeschichte, wo also die sämtliche Kreditkartendatensätze durchsucht worden sind, Operation Mikado. Und da ist natürlich schon die Frage, also warum soll man nicht auch mit möglicherweise illegalen Sachen dagegenhalten? Ich meine, vielleicht ist es ja auch sogar cool, wenn man halt mal irgendwie in einen Eintrag hat, eine Vorstrafe oder sowas, weil man irgendwo, sag ich mal, auf einen Schornstein geklettert ist und da ein Plakat aufgehangen hat. Ja, so what? Also das ist jetzt auch keine Sache.
Wir leben eben in einer Welt, in der, ich sag mal, auch plakativ die Springerpresse definiert, was Anstand ist und was nicht. Und in der Welt gibt es kaum Leute, die mutig genug sind, eine Vorstrafe zu kassieren.
Na, ich kann eher, aber auch, also ich beobachte im Moment auch die Diskussion im Club. Ich meine, um genau das Thema, wo sind die Grenzen jetzt, inwieweit hat die Hackerethik noch Bestand oder kann Bestand haben, wo, ich sag mal, die andere Seite sich permanent nicht an ihre eigenen Regeln hält. Und da sehe ich schon teilweise sowas wie eine online Gewaltspirale auf uns zukommen.
Da pfeife ich aber auch dann wirklich auf die Hackerethik. Wenn ich dem brandenburgischen Innenminister die Hammelbeine langziehen kann, dann mache ich das. Und da ist mir jeder Hackerethik wirklich egal.
Was ja wichtig ist in dem Kontext, ist dann eben gerade, dass der Chaos Computer Club als Institution sozusagen sich überlegen sollte, ob er als Club diese rechtliche Auseinandersetzung führt. Weil ich meine, als Einzelperson, wenn du als Einzelperson illegale Aktionen begehst, als Aktivist, dann hast du natürlich immer das Problem, dass er danach extrem arm sein kann. Du bist dann irgendwie verklagt, es kostet dich unglaublich viel Geld, was du dir nicht leisten kannst, hast Vorstrafen und so weiter. Und an dieser Stelle ist es natürlich exakt Aufgabe, so eine Institution und eine Instanz wie des Chaos Computer Clubs das offiziell zu übernehmen. Und sozusagen dann als Schirmherr für solche illegalen Aktionen dazustehen, weil dann natürlich auch diese Verantwortung ein bisschen zerstreut werden kann. Weil man dann quasi ein Vorurlaub hat.
Das ist der Club tatsächlich auch. Vielleicht ist es in den letzten Jahren nicht so präsent, nicht mehr so wichtig geworden. Aber gerade in der Anfangszeit der Club, der Club ist ja hauptsächlich dafür auch gegründet worden. Also in der Anfangszeit gab es viele Sachen, wo also der Club wirklich sich da vorgestellt hat, gesagt hat, okay, ja, wir wissen und wir haben und mit den Schultern zucken. Und nee, tut uns heil, wir können keinen Namen nennen. Geht nicht. Also genau für so Sachen und im Prinzip auch mit der Presse reden und auch Informationen in geordneten Bahnen nach außen zu geben. Das ist ja genau auch die Aufgabe des Clubs. Im Moment gibt es leider nicht so viel, wem wir da schützen können. Also uns wäre es lieber, wenn wir jede Woche irgendwie mit Anwältentermin und Gerichte bei... Jede Woche ein WTX hat.
Ja, genau. Man kann sich natürlich auch mal selber überlegen, was man jetzt an etwas massiveren Aktionen machen könnte. Dazu muss man natürlich ein bisschen sich überlegen, wie weit man die Hacker-Ethik jetzt mal vielleicht dem Zeitgeist anpassen müsste oder nicht. Ich meine, da kann man ja vielleicht auch mal die Hörer fragen. Sollte der Chaos Computer Club weitergehen als bisher oder nicht?
Was für eine wunderbare Frage. 0331 70 97 110. Sollte der CCC weitergehen als vorher? Debbie, vielen Dank. Die war schneller als wir. Jetzt müssen wir Nachrichten. Danach gehen wir weiter.
Das Schöne an Fotos ist, man kann sie sich immer und immer wieder angucken. Und das sollte man auch. Fritz präsentiert Fotos. Fotos ab 21 Uhr in Lido, Berlin Kreuzberg.
Mehr Infos und Fotos. Und das hört man.
Um 2 nach 12.
Fritz.
Info.
Nachrichten.
Mit Mario Bart.
Im Fall Kornatz sind 5 Angehörige des Bundeswehrkommandos Spezialkräfte streng abgestürmt von der Öffentlichkeit vor dem Verteidigungsausschuss gehört worden. Sie sollten unter anderem die Zustände in einem US-gefangenen Lager in Kandahar in Afghanistan schildern, in dem Kornatz Ende 2001-2002 festgehalten wurde. Nach Angaben des in Bremen geborenen Türken wurde er dort auch von deutschen Soldaten misshandelt. Das Verteidigungsministerium weist diese Vorwürfe zurück. Der Absturz eines Stahlträgers von der Fassade des Berliner Hauptbahnhofs hätte nach Einschätzung des Architekten von Gerkhan vermieden werden können. Von Gerkhan sagte vor dem Verkehrsausschuss des Bundestages, er habe ursprünglich Haltvorrichtungen für die Träger geplant. Diese seien aber unter der Regie der Bahn bei der weiteren Bauausführung weggelassen worden. Bahnvorstandsmitglied Wieshäu wies jede Verantwortung zurück. Potsdam Stadtverordnete haben im dritten Anlauf einen Landtagsneubau auf dem Areal des früheren Stadtschlosses zugestimmt. Es gab 29 Ja-Stimmen, 16 Ablehnungen und 3 Enthaltungen. Zum Sport. In der Fußball-Bundesliga hat Hertha BSC auswärts gegen Hannover 96 0 zu 5 verloren. Energie Cottbus trennte sich vom Hamburger SV 1 zu 1. In den weiteren Mittwochspartien spielten Leverkusen gegen Bremen 0 zu 2, Mainz gegen Dortmund 1 zu 0 und Schalke gegen Aachen 2 zu 1. Der FC Bayern München hat Trainer Felix Magath gefeuert. Der Verein gab die Entscheidung am Nachmittag bekannt. Bis zum Saisonende wird der ehemalige Trainer Ottmar Hitzfeld die Bayern leiten. Auch Borussia München-Gladbach braucht einen neuen Trainer. Jupp Heynckes erklärte am Mittag seinen Rücktritt. In der Basketball-Bundesliga hat Alba Berlin nach einer Heimniederlage gegen Spaniens Basketball-Top-Team Real Madrid kaum noch Chancen auf den Viertelfinaleinzug im Julep Cup. Die Berliner verloren das Achtelfinal-Hinspiel 65 zu 74. Wetter Heute Nacht kommen von Norden immer mehr Wolken zu und so die bringen auch Regen mit. Die Tiefstwerte liegen bei 4 bis 2 Grad. Dazu ist es ziemlich windig. Am Tag dann meist sonnig und trocken bei Höchstwerten bis 8 Grad. Auf folgenden Autobahnabschnitten sind derzeit Schwertransporte unterwegs, die nicht überholt werden können. A10 Schönefelder Kreuz Richtung Schwanenberg zwischen Schönefelder Kreuz und Raststätte Seeberg. A13 Dresden Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Schwarzheide und Schönefelder Kreuz. Und A24 Berliner Ring Richtung Schwerin zwischen Reichwitz Stockdorse und Parchim. A113 Autozubringer Dresden Treptow Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Am Schönefelder Kreuz gab es einen Unfall an der Ausfahrt zur A10 in Richtung Frankfurt. Dort gibt es Behinderungen. Rundstadtverkehr Berlin-Tempel auf Schöneberg. Die Motzner Straße ist in Höhe Nunsdorfer Ring nach einem Unfall komplett gesperrt. Sonst überall eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Mario, 5 nach halb 12.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6, dann Fritz in Berlin.
Chaosradio 120 ist es, was ihr hört. Ziviler Ungehorsam für Anfänger. So, jetzt haben wir alle lecker Schokolädchen gegessen. Das heißt, die nächsten 20 Minuten werdet ihr, obwohl wir nicht essen, noch Schmatzgeräusche vernehmen. So ist das, ein Schokolade-Essen-Radio machen. Wir sind solche Profis auch, ich finde das super hier. Ihr hört das Chaosradio 120 und...
Das ist mal ein anderes Hintergrund.
Chaosradio 120 Revolution, nein nicht Revolution, sondern Ziviler Ungehorsam für Anfänger. Kommt Wasser mit, die ganzen Leute. Wir wollen mit euch darüber sprechen, was ihr tun könnt, was wir tun können, um uns zu wehren gegen die zunehmende Einschränkung von Bürgerrechten, von bürgerlichen Freiheiten, sei es durch die biometrischen Pässe, durch die Telekommunikationsüberwachung, durch Videoüberwachung, aber auch durch die Online-Durchsuchung des heimischen PCs, wo also die Behörden... Der Bundestrojaner... .der sogenannten Bundestrojaner, wo also die Behörden auf dem PC rumwühlen können. Die sind bei uns, während wir im Internet sind.
Das wär Sehwofer, der ist doch vorher auch ein Trojaner gewesen. 0331 70 97 110. Matthias?
Ja, schönen guten Abend, ich grüße euch.
Guten Abend.
Wo schränken sie dich ein?
Oh, ja, also ich muss mal eben ganz kurz ein bisschen ausruhen. Ich bin selbstständig, bin kleiner Transportunternehmer. Und wir haben in Deutschland die Maut. Wobei die Maut an sich mich nicht stört, weil ich sie für richtig halte. Weil wir im Ausland ja auch für die Nutzung der Autobahn bezahlen müssen. Und so sehe ich das auch. Aber? Aber das ganze Mautsystem von Tollcollect ist so aufgebaut, dass wenn ich mit meinem LKW, sofern ich ein Onboard-Unit, das heißt den Rechner im Auto habe, von Tollcollect, unter der Mautbrücke die Firma Tollcollect sämtliche Daten von mir hat, nachvollziehen kann, wo mein LKW sich befindet.
Nicht nur dein LKW, sondern auch dein PKW.
Ja, genau, genau, richtig. Weil es wird ja jedes Kennzeichner fast, nicht nur das von dem LKW. Bei uns LKW kommt das dazu, dass durch das Onboard-Unit der LKW überall geortet werden kann. Ich meine, auf die Stasi wurde geschimpft und die muss weg. Und hast du nicht gesehen und in und her.
Jeder LKW hat einen eingebauten Peilsender jetzt.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, meine LKWs haben keinen.
Keine Onboard-Unit?
Nein, weil ich es nicht einsehe, dass ich irgendwem da die Möglichkeit gebe, nachzuvollziehen, ob ich mein LKW...
Ich dachte, den müsste man haben.
Nein, du kannst auch von Hand einen buchen.
Man kann das auch manuell machen, an Tankstellen oder Raststätten. Es ist sehr zeitaufwendig. Wir haben aber drei Angestellte. Wir haben da ein ausgeklügeltes System. Das klappt ganz gut. Wobei ich jetzt dazu sagen muss, der Staat tritt mir als Unternehmer... So ging es immer nur, da schränke ich mich dermaßen ein, weil ich werde gezwungen, auf die Autobahn zu fahren. Man sieht es immer mehr, dass die Bundes- und Landstraßen für den Schwerverkehr gesperrt werden. Und ich als Unternehmer gar nicht mehr die Möglichkeit habe, zu sagen, da kann ich Kosten einsparen.
Ich habe in einem Ort gewohnt, der regelmäßig von Hunderten Schwertransporten durchfahren wurde. Weil sich dadurch ein paar Kilometer sparen ließen, die sonst über die Autobahn außenrum hätte gefahren werden müssen. Ich wäre froh gewesen, hätte man die gezwungen, über die Autobahn zu fahren und nicht durch unser kleines Dörfchen in der Voreifel, wo wir gewohnt haben. Weil das war wirklich die totale Katastrophe. Es hat gestunken. Es war laut, es sind ständig irgendwie Leute verunfallt.
Ja, ich wohne auch an der Bundesstraße.
Aber sag mal, seid ihr da allein oder tauscht ihr dich mit anderen aus dem Gewerbe auch aus? Haben da auch andere Firmen, andere Unternehmer möglicherweise Bedenken oder stehst du da allein da?
Es ist eine Vielzahl von den Unternehmern. Im Unternehmerverband ist man da irgendwo auch am Amok laufen. Ja, ja, das ist zum Beispiel, ich sag mal, wenn ich jetzt als Unternehmer eine Preisvorgabe habe von dem Kunde X, der sagt, okay, das gebe ich für die Tour aus, dann kalkuliere ich das durch. Und es ist zum Beispiel, wenn ich von Magdeburg nach Hamburg fahre, dann kann ich die B71 fahren und die B4, die Landstraße, die bin ich jahrelang gefahren.
Aber Moment, das ist ja gegen die Maut als solche oder gegen die Strecke. Also ich meine jetzt eher gegen diese Überwachungsgeschichte. Weil du sagst, du hast keine Onboard-Unit, du willst keinen Peilsender haben, sondern du buchst dich manuell ein. Ist das ein Punkt oder geht es halt wirklich immer nur um die Maut, die Kosten und Geld?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung, ich bin jahrelang die Strecken so gefahren und verstehe natürlich auch die Anwohner. Weil ich wohne selber auch an einer B71, das ist eine vielbefahrene Bundesstraße. Ich habe selber auch zwei Kinder, die auch an der Hauptstraße leben. Aber ich sag mal so, die Kommunen und, und, und haben immer gesagt, es ist kein Geld da. Aber jede Ortschaft hat erst mal irgendwo bündig vor und nach der Ortschaft einen Kreisel gebaut. Kann man da nicht irgendwo eine Umgebungsstraße um größere Orte, wo zum Beispiel Schulen oder Kindergärten sind, umbauen?
Warum?
Du kannst aber die Autobahn fahren.
Ja, wenn, wenn es ist, du musst das jetzt mal so sehen. Du fährst jetzt eine Strecke von A nach B, suchst dir aus, ok, das ist die kürzeste Strecke, die fahre ich jetzt, weil sie für dich, weil sie für dich bequem ist.
Na gut, da geht es aber, da geht es aber um Geld und das, das ist nicht das Thema unserer Sendung jetzt gerade, glaube ich.
Doch, also ich, ich, ich, doch, ich bin, äh.
Nein, ist nicht das Thema unserer Sendung. Was das Thema unserer Sendung ist, das sagen wir.
Nein, aber es ist, der Staat schränkt mich als Menübürgerein, weil ich nicht frei wählen kann, wo ich, ähm, zum Beispiel, ich zahle ja auch Steuern von meinen LKWs.
Na gut, da machst du es dir aber, da machst du es dir ein bisschen einfach. Du willst nicht, du willst nicht eingeschränkt werden in der Wahl der Strecke, die du mit deinem LKW fährst, auf Kosten derer, die an dieser Strecke wohnen. Und das ist die Abwägung, die die Kommune macht. Die sagt, äh, sorry, aber das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist der Kommune egal, dass es dich mehr Geld kostet, über die Autobahn außen rumzufahren, und im Zweifelsfall mehr Zeit zu haben. Aber damit schweifen wir richtig weit ab gerade.
Das ist ja, das ist ja das, was ich nicht verstehe. Die Anwohner der Ortschaften und und und, die sind jahrelang amok gelaufen und haben gesagt, hier muss irgendwo ein Riegel vorhanden. Da hat sich der Staat die Scheißdrunge gekümmert.
Auf einmal geht es um Geld, da funktioniert es.
Auf einmal geht es um Geld und jetzt heißt es ja, weil die Bürger ja entlastet werden müssen und die Straßen, die Landstraße.
Das passt zwar nicht ganz hin, aber es ist ein guter Punkt. Ich glaube, wenn man den Menschen klarmacht, dass das, was an Überwachung passiert, auch wirklich wahnsinnig teuer ist.
Ich glaube, es ist auch ein sehr gutes Beispiel dafür, wie eine Maßnahme dann den Schwanz anderer Maßnahmen nach sich zieht. So wie dieses Mautsystem führt im ersten Schritt dann zu einer Mautvermeidung, die dann wieder im nächsten Schritt eine Gegenreaktion bedarf, in dem dann wiederum exzessiv Strecken gesperrt werden, um der Mautvermeidung zu begegnen.
Aber es währt sich nicht wirklich jemand dagegen. Es geht ja auch wirklich nur ums Geld. Es geht eben niemandem. Das nervt mich ein bisschen.
Aber auf den Strecken, die jetzt zum Beispiel von uns LKW, oder von uns Transportunternehmen gemien werden müssen, auf diesen Strecken, kenne ich, ich bin 17 Jahre unterwegs, meine ganze Familie ist unterwegs, da sind so viele kleine Unternehmen, die insolvent gegangen sind, weil kein Publikumsverkehr mehr da war. Da sind so viele Tankstellenangestellte entlassen worden.
Ja, aber das nennt man Markt. So ist das. Und Markt ist nicht Grund, so ist es eben. Als die Todesstrafe abgeschafft wurde, da gab es auch Arbeitslose. Weißt du, so ist es eben. Aber das Problem ist, dass außerhalb dieses Marktes da passiert nämlich nur was anderes. Da passieren bürgerliche Freiheiten, die eingeschränkt werden.
Bist du denn mal eine Frage als Transportunternehmer? Es gibt doch jetzt eine neue Regelung im Versand von Gütern, wo man dann für die Sicherheit bestimmter Sendung auch bestimmte Garantieerklärungen abgeben muss, bist du davon eigentlich auch betroffen?
Das ist hier zum Beispiel die ISO-Norm. Nee, da bin ich nicht betroffen.
Also speziell im grenzüberschreitenden Verkehr?
Wir fahren europaweit und ich muss sagen, da haben wir eigentlich kaum Kontakt mit oder wenig Probleme, wenn wir mal Kontakt damit haben. Das heißt, Ladung ist das einzige, was uns irgendwo aufgelegt wird. Wenn wir die Ware befördern, ist das die korrekte Ladungssicherung oder so?
Im Rahmen der Terrorabwehr wurden ja jetzt verschiedene Maßnahmen beschlossen, um zu verhindern, dass bestimmte Güter, die von Terroristen genutzt werden können, um da einen Riegel drauf zu haben. Aber das ist noch nicht bis zu euch durchgedrungen, so in die Praxis.
Bei uns ist es so, ich mach Autotransporte, Autoverführung und wir fahren auch viel Export, das heißt Afrika, Libanon, Syrien, Irak. Und da ist es teilweise, zum Beispiel in Italien, in den Häfen, dass man, bevor man in den Hafen reinfährt, erst mal komplett die Autos durchgeschaut werden, ob da irgendwie was dran sein könnte und und und. Okay. Nicht, dass da irgendwelche Waffen Richtung...
Dauert das länger? Also bist du vorher schneller durchgekommen durch die Grenzen?
Ich selber hab, muss ich ehrlich gestehen, das gar nicht so. Das ist, weiß ich nicht, ob der deutsche Unternehmer so hoch angesehen wird, dass er da gleich rein gelassen wird.
Alles klar, tschau. Was ich daran bei allem Abschweifen ganz interessant finde, ist, sobald es Geld kostet, ist es ein Thema. Und zwar ist das bei allen Sachen so.
Auch bei den Reisepassen haben sich die Leute aufgeregt, weil sie jetzt 59 statt 26, aber kein Arsch richtig drüber auf, dass sie jetzt biometrisch sind.
Aber vielleicht ist das genau der Schlüssel. Vielleicht ist es tatsächlich der Preis oder überhaupt der Geldbeutel, das Vehikel, wie man es in die Leute rein kriegt. Vielleicht ist es auch einfach nur die Maut, das Vehikel dafür, dass die Leute endlich mal den Mumm haben, zu sagen, hier fährt jetzt kein LKW mehr durch. Vielleicht muss man tatsächlich versuchen, alles in einen Preis umzurechnen, damit die Menschen verstehen.
Das zieht das Ganze auf so eine Kosten-Nutzen-Kalkulation unter. Darum geht es ja eigentlich nicht. Es geht ja eher darum, dass man Werte verkauft, dass man einfach widersprüchliche Werte hat wie Sicherheit und Freiheit.
Guck dir das Fernsehprogramm an und finde jemanden, der viel fernsieht, der überhaupt noch irgendwie einen Begriff von Werten hat.
Aber gerade ist es wirklich nicht so schlimm.
Ich finde viel Interesse an Werten und solchen Sachen. Auch wenn ich mich mit normalen Leuten unterhalte, wie viel Fernsehen. Ich weiß, wird es nicht so weit weg. Ich muss es einfach noch ein bisschen bewusster... Ich bin da nicht so positiv.
Ich würde über die Kosten-Geschichte zurückkommen. Das ist natürlich auch ein Argument, was immer häufig gezogen wird. Es geht um die Kosten. Kameras in U-Bahn, Graffiti, Vandalismus-Vermeidung. Was auch hilft, bei diesen Kosten-Geschichten auch wirklich mal konsequent zu hinterfragen und auch zu zerlegen. Es hat übrigens im Nachgang von einer Chaosradio-Sendung ein Hörer sich mal die Mühe gemacht und hat quasi anhand der Zahlen nachgewiesen, dass sich der Vandalismus durch die Einführung der Videokameras in den U-Bahn auf die S-Bahn verschoben hat. Auch anhand der Zahlen, der Schäden, die da aufgetreten sind. Das ist eine ganz interessante Geschichte. Klar, bei den Pässen wird ja möglicherweise auch mit optimierten Grenzkontrollen argumentiert. Bei den Wahlcomputern wird gesagt, die sind billiger. Wenn man sich aber wirklich mal die Mühe macht, diese Kostengeschichten zu zerlegen, dann kommt man da möglicherweise auch noch mal auf interessante Argumentationsschienen.
Das ist die BK aus Radio 120, Ziviler Ungehorsam für Anfänger. Das ist unser Thema. Hallo Dennis.
Also was ich jetzt, weißt du, ich hab jetzt einen Haufen Zetteln gemacht, muss ich sagen, hier im Laufe des Abends schon, weil man ein bisschen am Überblick behalten muss, womit schon alles drin war.
Es hört ja nicht jeder von Anfang an zu, von daher kann man auch mal zugesprungen machen.
Ja, das hat schon mal alles ein bisschen aufgerochen.
Aber was mir jetzt eben noch aufgefallen ist, also die Diskussion mit dem Geld und Talk-Collect, man sagt, dass man leicht über das Geld argumentieren kann, finde ich eigentlich, kann zwar vielleicht in einem einzelnen Bereich was bringen, aber ich finde, das trifft den Kern nicht. Dann werden die Leute sagen, es ist allzu teuer, das ist das, was ich auch aus dem Umkreis immer so höre, mit dem biometrischen Pest, ja, kostet das doch wieder und so. Dadurch regen sich die Leute halt drüber auf. Und das finde ich dann halt wieder schade, weil da nichts darunter steht.
Das andere verstehen sie eben nicht. Zumindest meine Theorie. Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Das ist halt die Frage, ob man das sozusagen akzeptieren kann und aber die Leute nutzen kann, um sozusagen mitzuschwimmen, mitschwimmen zu lassen, quasi eine kritische Masse zu erzeugen, wenn es dagegen geht. Oder eben zu sagen, nee, das ist blöd und wir wollen aber, dass ihr das versteht und wollen wenigstens auch den Beifall von den Richtigen haben und aus einem richtigen Grund und so was. Und die Leute sollen davon überzeugt sein. Also das Problem ist ja mit der Revolution, wenn es irgendwie jetzt da fünf Leute sind, die sagen, wir stürzen jetzt den Staat, das bringt ja nichts. Die anderen müssen ja auch mitmachen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, die Leute verstehen einfach nicht, was die letzte Konsequenz dahinter ist. Man müsste da glaube ich noch viel mehr aufklären, was wirklich der Boden dieser Geschichte ist. Ich meine, die ersten Effekte, die man so fühlt, sind jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig pressierend, aber dieser Abbrauch von Grundrechten und was es überhaupt erst mal bedeutet, in einem Staat zu leben, der halt bestimmte Grundrechte technisch abgebaut hat und dann nur noch quasi formal Makulatur auf dem Papier stehen hat, das ist eine ganz andere Geschichte. Und das ist eine Frage, wie schafft man dafür ein Bewusstsein und wie schafft man dann ein Problembewusstsein dafür, dass das irgendwie so ein technisches Problem ist?
Als Transportvehikel mit Sicherheit denke ich schon einen Ansatz, dass man das sagen kann, dass man das auch machen kann, dass man überhaupt die Themen mal in die Medien reinbekommt, wenn es dann nur so als Seitenthema ist.
Ja, aber wie bekommst du die Themen in die Medien?
Ja, wenn du jetzt sagst, mit dem Geld, das ist natürlich schon mal so vielleicht einer von den wenigen Ansatzpunkten, die man momentan noch hat, sag ich mal. Weil bei dem, was mich auch stört, so Sachen wie die Datenschutzbeauftragten. Das ist für mich so ein großes Tuch, da liest man dann vielleicht mal was im Internet auf Blogs, was davon. Ja, es sind Papiertiger.
Ich habe übrigens den Berliner Datenschutzbeauftragten am 26. Januar. Montag, den 26. Januar ist der Berliner Datenschutzbeauftragte hier zu Gast. Da kannst du dann auch noch mal durchläuten und ein bisschen einschenken oder Fragen stellen.
Vielleicht, ich meine, wo wir gerade von Aufklärung sprechen, vielleicht warum, also wo das Problem mit den biometrischen Pässen eigentlich liegt. Es liegt weniger vielleicht darin, dass die Dinger teurer sind und das jetzt, also die Pässe an sich sind auch fast noch das geringere Problem. Das Problem ist die Datensammlung, die dadurch, also dadurch wird erstmalig eine Datensammlung biometrietauglicher Bilder angelegt, die für sich genommen, so wie es jetzt ist, zwar immer noch in dem, soweit ich das sehe, nicht zentral bisher in einer großen Datenbank liegen, sondern in den jeweiligen Ämtern noch verwahrt werden. Aber so im nächsten Schritt geht es ja jetzt darum, diese ganzen Daten dann in eine große Datenbank zusammenzupacken.
Genau mit dieser Rede hast du 98 Prozent der Bevölkerung ausgeschlossen, weil die schon zu Anfang zu Anfang deiner Rede sagen, ach komm, geh mir weg mit all diesem, das ist mir viel zu abstrakt. Und sie werden es abgehoben oder sonst wie nicht.
Das eigentliche Problem ist, dass man im Zusammenhang wieder immer muss, ja das ist das Problem, dass es kompliziert ist, aber im Zusammenhang wiederum mit den Überwachungskameras ist es dann langfristig, wir reden hier nicht von drei, vier, fünf Jahren, sondern vielleicht eher von Zeiträumen von zehn bis zwanzig Jahren, wo es dann möglich sein wird, anhand der Kameras und der entsprechenden Dateien mit deinen biometrischen Gesichtsmerkmalen, dich wirklich auf Schritt und Tritt zu beobachten.
Aber der Pass ist doch wirklich ein wunderbares Beispiel. Wenn ich mir meine Mutter angucke, meine Mutter ist ein ganz normaler Mensch, die ist mittlerweile 70 Jahre alt, die hat einen ganz normalen Volksschulabschluss gemacht, hat einen ganz normalen Beruf gehabt und und und und, also völlig normaler Mensch mit einem kleinen Eigenheim irgendwo in Westdeutschland. So, wenn ich meiner Mutter komme mit, und genauso war es, ich komme meiner Mutter mit, hier biometrische Daten im Pass und zentrale Datensammlung und und und und, da sagt meine Mutter, ach komm, hör doch auf. Ja, ich bin jetzt 70 Jahre alt, bis das alles, das ist so alles gar nicht so schlimm. Wenn ich meiner Mutter sage, so übrigens, du musst nächstes Jahr deinen Pass verlängern lassen, das kostet jetzt vierfache, dann ist meine Mutter empört. So, und genau das ist es, was ich haben will. Ich möchte bitte, dass die Masse, also dass der Mann auf der Straße, wie auch immer du es nennen magst, empört ist. Und mir ist erstmal scheißegal, warum er empört ist. Hauptsache, er bewegt sich.
Ich sag's mal so, dass man dafür die Masse erst mal nur, egal, ist so ein Ziel, dass man dahinter hat.
Und mit so einem abstrakten, die Datenbank dahinter und so. Das ist alles schlimm. Ich begreif das auch, aber das ist Unpopulismus. Du musst populistisch sein, das glaube ich.
Das interessiert keinen. Und das, was ich auch schlimm finde, das sind das, dass die Leute halt so in ihrem normalen Leben drin hängen und da auch gar keinen Kopf für haben. Ich meine, dann sind so Payback mentalisiert. Da ist sowieso alles dann, jedes Cent wird dann aufgegriffen.
Wir hatten natürlich da auch schon mal auf ähnlichen Argumentationen auf dem Niveau, würde halt zum Beispiel so aussehen, wie dass es demnächst dann gezielte Anschläge beispielsweise gibt, in dem ich etwa Minen bauen kann, die dann in die Luft gehen, wenn jemand mit einem bestimmten Pass in der Tasche darüber marschiert.
Das ist natürlich auch sehr abtrocknet. Bei mir persönlich ist es so, dass einfach diese Akte des Fingerabdrucks abgeben. Das ist einfach so, da ist alles vorbei, da ist total Schluss. Das ist denke ich auch eine Sache, wo ich noch mal persönlich meine Hoffnung habe, dass da noch ein paar mehr Leute aufstehen werden.
Obwohl vielleicht noch das geringste Problem ist mit dem Fingerabdruck. Wo die Leute denken, das ist was Klassisches auch, was auch vielleicht so eine Zeitgeistfrage ist, was das Leute, weil das kennt man ja, sage ich, aus dem Fernsehen, Fingerabdrücke abgeben, vielleicht kriminell, da kann man auch eher mit argumentieren als mit modernen Medien. Da sind die Leute eh noch so was von unsicher drin, damit umzugehen. Wenn ich das sehe im Freundeskreis, jetzt nur mal so ein kleines Beispiel vielleicht, hier ist ja dieses tolle Studieverzeichnis und da eine Bekannte, die hat dann halt einen Accounter gehabt und auf einmal hieß es dann, da hat mir jemand ein anderes Bild reingemacht. Da sag ich, ja wie kann das denn sein? Ja, hat vielleicht, ich sag, er muss irgendwie da ein Passwort rausbekommen, und da wäre ich natürlich toll umgefallen und hätte mir Gedanken gemacht, das ist partiert und sie hat dann einfach ihr Bild wieder reingestellt und damit war für sie die Sache erledigt. Und das sind halt so Sachen, da wird nicht drüber nachgedacht. Es wird halt einfach so, sag ich mal, die Medien werden einfach so, vor allen Dingen diese Internet-Social-Networks einfach genutzt und man macht sich gar keine Gedanken da so richtig, was dahintersteht. Da ist kein Umgangsgedanke da, finde ich. Das ist das, was da überhaupt total fehlt. Man hat da noch keine Erfahrung in der Gesellschaft damit. Auch vielleicht die Politiker nicht, die jetzt auch noch in einer Generation drin hängen, die vielleicht auch wie mit Killerspielen gar nichts anfangen können. Die haben überhaupt keinen Bezug dazu, die kennen das nicht, die kennen nur die Schlagworte und danach wird ja da auch entschieden, sage ich mal, in Ministerien.
Wie entschieden würdest du denn gegen sowas vorgehen? Wie entschlossen bist du da?
Ja, das ist genau so ein Punkt, muss ich sagen. Weil ich sitze dann, sage ich mal, so in meinem Kämmerlein oft und mache mir schrecklich viele Gedanken. Das Ganze in die Tat umzusetzen ist natürlich immer ganz schwer. Was ich da ganz gut finde, ist erstmal so ein Ansatz, dass man die Leute wirklich für jetzt, sagst du das Geld, vielleicht auch mal andere Leute mit ansteckt oder auch einfach diese Sachen mit diesen Zettelchen am Flughafen. Dass man da einfach kleine Zeichen setzt. Weil jetzt, sage ich mal, das ist das Problem für mich, was ich auch für die anderen Leute so empfinde. Jetzt aus seinem Leben, sage ich mal, komplett auszusteigen und für die Sache Feuer und Flamme zu sein, da ganz zu brennen, das kann nicht jeder, vielleicht auch vom mentalen Vorstandpunkt her, der da zwar mitfiebert und in der Sache dabei ist, aber...
Wobei wahrscheinlich... Gut, wie nah bist du jetzt persönlich an deinen Grenzen ran, wo du sagen würdest, bis hierher und nicht weiter? Wie strapaziert ist deine Toleranz im Moment? Was würdest du sagen?
Also ich sag mal, bei mir ist das noch so eine Vorahnungsstufe. Ich bin jetzt noch nicht so, dass ich sage, ich habe akute in meinem Leben schon große Beeinträchtigungen. Das fängt jetzt an, wir fliegen bald nach Spanien. Allein, dass ich mir da schon Gedanken machen muss mit diesen lächerlichen Pinzette nicht im Handgepäck und all so Späße. Und diesen Shampoo-Geschichten. Und da war es halt auch so, dass wir da oben in der Uni saßen, und haben darüber gesprochen, dass wir das nicht dürfen und so. Und da hat sich halt zwar so ein gewisses Raunen durch die Menge gewegt, aber so richtig das Thema aufzugreifen, war da halt auch nicht. Das wurde dann einfach als unangenehm angenommen und als Sache, die man beachten muss. Und irgendwie auch im Unterschältigen als Blödsinn. Aber da ist es halt schwer dann, auch wenn man, sag ich mal, dann dahin muss oder irgendwo hin will. Und dann ist man ja irgendwie dazu gezwungen, vielleicht auch beruflich dann den ganzen Spaß mitzumachen. Und das ist ja das Schwierige daran, finde ich.
Naja, ich meine also ein Problem, das bei diesen ganzen Maßnahmen, bei diesen ganzen technischen Maßnahmen ja auch eine Rolle spielt, ist, dass das eigentlich alles Experten-Systeme sind. Also das sind alles recht komplexe technische Vorgänge, recht komplexe technische Geräte, Programme, die da drauf laufen. Und die sind halt zum einen nicht durchsichtig für den Durchschnittsanwender. Und zum anderen kann man halt eben diesen kleinen Widerstand, also einfach sein Nicht-Einverständnis damit zu zeigen, indem man es irgendwie vermeiden will oder sowas. Das lässt, das kann man irgendwie fast gar nicht. Und da finde ich zum Beispiel, dass es halt eine ganz entscheidende Aufgabe und eigentlich eine Pflicht auch von technischen Experten da dann auch Gegenmaßnahmen zu produzieren und Gegenmaßnahmen zur Verfügung zu stellen. Wie halt eben Programme, die Privatheit schützen.
Das finde ich auch ganz wichtig.
Programme, die das Handy vor dem Abhören schützen und wo man zum Beispiel die Vorratsdaten...
Das kann man auch tun, dass Leute einem, sag ich mal, auch programmiertechnisch einfach Sachen an die Hand geben, die einem helfen, sich ein bisschen besser gestärkt zu fühlen, dass man nicht, sag ich mal, als Gedanke ganz allein ist in der Sache. Weil ich denke, da gibt es noch viele mehr, die dann einfach nur...
Ja, ganz genau. Und man braucht auch ganz einfache Sachen wirklich. Ich sag das auch immer so, der Linus-Commander und diesen PGP-Jungs, das ist alles noch viel zu schwierig, um das wirklich auch in die Menge zu bringen. Ja, man braucht da so ein Einklick-bedienerfreundlich-Wizard-Ding, der das irgendwie für einen macht und dann ist das fertig. Aber das ist wirklich eine wichtige Aufgabe, die im Moment ganz dringend ansteht. Und die auch Leute wie uns angeht, also Technikaktivisten wie den Chaos Computer Club, diese Sachen zu produzieren und zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Da seh ich eben auch ein ganz großes Problem. Das ist auch so eine Erfahrung, die ich in vielen Jahren im Umgang mit dem CCC feststelle. So eine gewisse, wie soll ich sagen, quasi-Aroganz. Das ist keine echte Arroganz, sondern das ist so dieses Hey, Moment mal, wir können euch nur sagen, das ist kaputt. Aber wie man es repariert, das müsst ihr euch schon selbst drauf schaffen. Und dabei verlieren die Leute, die wirklich Ahnung haben von der Materie, von der Technik, die es dazu beherrschen gilt, sehr schnell aus den Augen, dass man sich um viele andere Dinge auch zu kümmern hat, dass man sich darum kümmern hat, vielleicht 10 Stunden am Tag arbeiten zu gehen und überhaupt nicht mehr die Muße hat, sich die Software drauf zu schaffen. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel immer mal wieder lese, so ja hier in GNU-PG, da ist irgendwie ein Sicherheits-Lag drin oder sowas, so ich hab's jetzt aufgedeckt, aber ich werd einen Teufel tun, das raus zu programmieren. Also das hab ich kürzlich in einem Blog gelesen, von jemandem, der so ein Sicherheits-Lag gefunden hat. Da frag ich mich dann auch, ja Baby, was soll der Scheiß? Ich sende mich hier um den Kopf und Kragen, indem ich die Innenminister beleidige. Dann ist es jetzt gefälligst auch dein Job, meine Verschlüsselungssoftware in Ordnung zu bringen. Was ist denn das? Das wird schon der zweite, der rausgeflogen ist, oder? Draußen der Einbeinige an der Hotline zuckt auch die Schultern, dann drück ich mal das Show um natürlich. Das ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat, das heißt es ist der Tag, in dem das Chaosradio stattfindet, heute mit der Ordnungszahl 120.
Ist das keine Ordnungszahl? Also das ist in der Sendung.
Ordnung muss sein. Ordnung, Sauberkeit, Anstand, Pünktlichkeit. Jetzt musst du sagen, das ist Herr Müller-Lüdenscheid. Ja, ja, aber es gibt Wichtigeres im Leben. Aber ich kann länger als sie. Jetzt sind wir wieder rausgekommen.
Ja, dabei hat es, du hast mich jetzt abgewirkt. Ich hatte noch einen wichtigen Punkt. Was wir gemerkt haben, viele Leute aus unserem Umfeld sind nun auch in allen möglichen Firmen, teilweise großen Firmen, wichtigen Firmen tätig. Also auch wir haben alle einen Berufs, oder die meisten haben ein Berufsleben. Und bauen System oder arbeiten auch an sensitiven Stellen. Und da haben wir die Erfahrung gemacht, dass das Aussprechen oder sich auch zu weigern, bestimmte Dinge zu tun, zu sagen, ne, diese Abhörschnittstelle programmiere ich jetzt nicht. Oder dafür gebe ich mich nicht her. Vergiss das, dass man dann ganz plötzlich einen Denkprozess, auch bei Leuten, die sich noch nie damit beschäftigt haben, in Gang setzt und plötzlich die gesamte Abteilung hinter einem steht und man feststellt, dass eigentlich jeder das schon immer scheiße fand, dass sich nur niemand getraut hat, das zu sagen, oder dass die Leute sich noch gar keine Gedanken darüber gemacht haben. Und dann kommt so eins zum anderen und plötzlich stellt man fest, dass man eben gar nicht alleine ist, sondern...
Vor allem muss man sich einfach klarmachen, dass wenn jemand in der Jobsituation ist, im Moment, der sich sowas erlauben kann, auch mal zur Not gefeuert zu werden, weil er sagt, nein, ich bau jetzt diese Schnittstelle da nicht ein, dass hier irgendwie abgehört werden kann, dann sind es im Moment gerade die Informatiker. Und da gibt es also überhaupt keinen Grund, da irgendwie mitzuschwimmen, wenn man denkt, naja, und ich werde nicht auffallen. Klar, Leute, steht auf. Und wie gesagt, die Erfahrung zeigt, es ist wirklich nicht schwer. Und wenn Sachen erstmal ausgesprochen werden, häufig finden sich dann auch Mitstreiter.
Es gibt wirklich sehr, sehr schnell sogar Mitstreiter, die derselben Meinung sind und vorher sich nicht getraut haben.
Ich meine, das ist so die eine Seite der Zivilcourage, nichts Schlechtes zu tun. Ich glaube, im Fall von technischen Umsetzungen reicht das einfach nicht, weil es einfach immer irgendeinen gibt, der das dann doch macht. Man muss einfach jetzt sozusagen Gegenmaßnahmen entwickeln, wenn man sich dann als auf der guten Seite sieht, oder man weiß auch, wie man da irgendwie was mit umgehen kann. Dann muss man einfach dagegen anentwickeln.
Und wie die aussehen, könnte noch mal eine Stunde Zeit darüber zu reden. Hallo, Joachim aus Regensburg. Ich lese hier legale Möglichkeiten der Aufruhr. Hast du eine Idee, die es zur Gegenmaßnahme entdeckt?
Also das Kostenargument kann man ja auch als Vorteil für uns sehen. Also wenn man zum Beispiel zeigt, dass es nichts kostet, Daten zu vermeiden. Wenn man zeigt, hey, lege eine Ubuntu zu dir ein und in 25 Minuten hast du ein funktionierendes Linux. Oder wenn man zeigt...
Mit dem aber bestimmte Dinge nicht funktionieren. Bitte? Mit dem aber bestimmte Dinge auch nicht funktionieren. Also da sind wir bei dem Thema, was Sandro ja auch eben aufgemacht hat, das FAS. Wenn ich mein macOS installiere und den Rechner einschalte, dann läuft das Ding. Dann funktioniert das. Und zwar funktioniert das im Wesentlichen so. Nicht unbedingt so, wie ich es gerne hätte, aber so, wie ich es erwarte und es einigermaßen fehler. Wenn ich dasselbe mit einem Linux mache, funktioniert das immer noch nicht. Das hab ich vor 10 Jahren probiert, da hat es nicht so funktioniert, wie ich das haben wollte. Und jetzt funktioniert das auch nicht. Ich bin gezwungen, mich in einem Maße mit dieser Technik zu beschäftigen. Dazu fehlt mir die Muße, dazu fehlt mir der Sachverstand und vielleicht sogar der Grips.
Du bist verdorben.
Nein, dazu fehlt mir der Grips, mein Lieber. Ich verstehe nicht, was da passiert.
Die Zeit auch einfach.
Das ist so das, was ich eben meinte, wo ich Sandro so beigesprungen bin. Es gibt einfach Leute, die haben den Sachverstand und die sollen den auch nutzen. Den vertraue ich ja auch. Also wenn Frank oder wenn Pawel sagt, ich programmiere, ich mach dir das so richtig, dann sag ich, hey, super, danke, dir vertraue ich das. Und das sollte man eigentlich ausnutzen, dieses Vertrauen auch einfach mitzunehmen als Währung.
Gut, aber das ist natürlich schon, also klar, wenn du Ubuntu CD hast, das ist ja basiert ja darauf genau, dass du denen vertraust, die haben da halt ein tolles System gemacht und da gibt es keine Hintertüren, da ist auch kein irgendwie treuernisches Pferd eingebaut. Das ist natürlich schon, also klar, Ubuntu ist jetzt wahrscheinlich auch ein ganz gutes Beispiel, weil es wirklich darauf ausgelegt ist, einfach einlegen, starten, installieren geht. Ach so, gut. Ja, also das ist jetzt sozusagen das Vorzeige Linux oder so.
Ach, verstehe.
Nö, ist nicht so schlimm. Aber klar, natürlich wäre es natürlich noch ein Schritt weiter dann zu sagen, okay, ich kauf jetzt eine Windows-CD, kack darauf und schick die an Microsoft zurück oder so. Nein, ich wollte sagen... Also, wie gesagt, das ist zwar immer ganz schön so, aber im Prinzip muss es immer noch einen Schritt weitergehen, denke ich.
Ja, aber man kann ja mittlerweile ganz gut zeigen, dass es nichts kostet und es auch gar nicht schwierig ist, dass man eigentlich praktisch kein Know-how braucht, um Daten zu vermeiden. Also Thunderbird zum Beispiel, das Email-Client, schnell installiert, hey, ein Plugin, oh, schon kann ich meine E-Mails verschlüsseln, ich muss gar nicht wissen, wie das geht.
Wobei, mit dem Nix-Kosten ist natürlich auch wieder relativ, das stimmt ja so auch nicht richtig, weil auch das Linux muss entwickelt werden, das heißt, da sitzen Leute, die sitzen in Firmen, das ist genau das gleiche wie mit dem Privatfernst, mit dem sogenannten Free TV. Das ist ja Unfug, das ist ja nicht frei, kostenlos, sondern das ist werbefinanziert, das heißt, du zahlst das nächsten Morgen beim Einkauf im Supermarkt und genauso ist es mit Linux natürlich auch nur noch ein bisschen weniger mittelbar. Aber anyway, du hast zumindest die Freiheit im Sinne von frei, das heißt, du kannst es halt auch verändern und weitergeben und wie auch immer.
Man kann ja zeigen, dass es Alternativen gibt, die kosten nichts. Man braucht relativ wenig Know-how, es funktioniert ziemlich gut. Und ich hab dir die Erfahrung gemacht, im privaten Bereich, da kann man auch ziemlich viele Leute mit anfixen und die bleiben dabei. Die haben dann sowohl Windows als auch Linux drauf, die gewöhnen sich dran. Im Prinzip Leute, die sich da auf dem Weg überzeugen lassen, das sind doch Verbündete, oder?
Ich denke auch, dass in Zukunft irgendwann vielleicht so ein Drittelmix aus den drei Mainstream-Systemen...
Glaubst du wirklich? Glaub ich nicht dran.
Nein?
Glaub ich, ich glaub da nicht dran. Nee, ich glaube Windows wird immer so eine...
Nein, die Leute kaufen gerade für Macs wie die Blöden. Das glaub ich nicht dran.
Ich glaub's auch. Also erstens ist Vista das letzte Betriebssystem, was Microsoft je entwickelt hat. Sie werden nie wieder ein neues Betriebssystem entwickeln können, weil Vista hat sich schon an die Grenzen des Machbaren gebracht. Sie werden es jetzt eigentlich nur noch Vista weiterentwickeln, Stück für Stück. Aber es wird keine Grund auf Neuentwicklung geben. Also das ist sozusagen für Microsoft das Ende der Fahnenstange erreicht.
Es werden echt viele Leute vergretzen.
Warum ist das so? Man hat es ja gesehen, sie waren irgendwie drei Jahre zu spät, haben drei Manager geführt. Also es hat fast die Firma kaputt gemacht jetzt, weil die Komplexität nicht mehr beherrschbar ist. Es ist einfach zu teuer, zu kompliziert. Und es ist einfach übersteigt im Moment. Ja, wir sind da an die Grenzen des Machbaren angekommen, was eine Firma auf diesem Globus an Betriebssystementwicklung leisten kann.
Was macht Apple anders?
Na ja, die Apple hat es ja früher an seine Grenzen gestoßen schon und sind dann deswegen auf Unix eigentlich gegangen und haben einen GUI drüber gesetzt. Insofern, also die hatten auch da ihr Waterloo. OS 9 war das glaube ich. Nein, nach US 9 haben sie fünf Jahre lang an dem Nachfolger entwickelt, den sie dann eingestampft haben und dann Next gekauft und eigentlich was Existierendes genommen. Also ich glaube auch, dass sich da einiges tun wird. Microsoft wird sicherlich übrig bleiben, aber man geht davon aus, dass es in zehn Jahren vermutlich fast nur noch Open Source Software geben wird mit einigen wenigen Ausnahmen. Das habe ich bei Gesprächen mit Investoren oft gehört. Das setzt sich auch ganz oben in den Köpfen mittlerweile fest, dass das nicht mehr aufzuhalten ist.
Die Programme sind ja auch überzeugend, das funktioniert ja tadellos.
Gut zu bedienen, da gibt mir gar keine Kompromisse mehr an.
Ja, bzw. man schreibt es eben um, bevor man hineingeht. Oder lässt es sich umschreiben von jemandem, den man dafür bezahlt. Das ist ja für dich auch in Ordnung.
Ja, aber das ist doch ein Weg, dem ganzen Überwachungsdruck auch zivil Ungehorsam entgegenzusetzen. Kein schlechter. Was ihr vorhin diskutiert habt, ihr habt ja aber offensichtlich illegale oder grenzwertige Aktionen nachgedacht. Ich weiß nicht, da fällt mir jetzt mal so ein Artikel in der Datenschleite ein. Weiß nicht, wo der drin stand, da ist es ja auch recht offensichtlich propagiert worden, dass es die einzige Möglichkeit ist, um, naja, Publikum, um irgendein Auditorium zu gewinnen.
Ja, der war von mir der Artikel.
Was hast du geschrieben, Sandro? Ich hab's nicht gelesen.
Na, eben auch, dass man mal ein bisschen vage, waghalsigere Aktionen wagen müsste, halt Sabotageaktionen in verschiedenen Bereichen, diese technischen Aktionen mal ausnutzen müsste, um mehr in die Medien und an die Öffentlichkeit zu kommen.
Das Vermlöffende ist, es passiert überhaupt keine Sabotage. Also die Zustände in den 70er Jahren, als es die RAF gab, die waren doch wesentlich, die waren doch nicht so schlimm wie heute eigentlich, oder? Also du konntest dich dem Staat oder dem Druck des Staates doch viel besser entziehen als einzelne, als du da heute noch zu leben bist.
Das war ein anderer gesellschaftlicher, gesellschaftlich moralischer Druck. Wahrscheinlich mehr und mehr so eine Ideologie noch, die die Reste des dritten Reichs, die dann noch so durch die Gesellschaft wehten.
Das war glaube ich so der Punkt. Heute ist das Problem der böse Kapitalismus. Also eigentlich, mich wundert im Grunde, dass nicht ständig versucht wird, irgendeine Bank anzuzünden. Das wird sowieso nicht klappen, weil da überall Wachleute rumstehen mittlerweile.
Es gibt eine schöne Künstlergruppe in den USA, die heißen RT Mark. Also RT Mark, wie die Mark. Und die haben quasi Schlagenprojekte vor, die man machen kann. Das sind so kleine, an sich lustige Aktionen, die aber auch einen gewissen Tiefgang haben. Und früher war das so, ich weiß nicht, ob sie das immer noch machen.
Also ohne tatsächlich Anschläge zu sein. Das Problem ist ja, wenn du die Leute in die Luft hast.
Früher haben sie quasi Belohnungen für Sabotageakte. Also wenn Leute in ihrer Firma, also sie haben gesagt, die und die Firma ist böse. Und wenn es da jemanden gibt, der die und die Sache möglicherweise machen kann, dann sozusagen als Ersatz dafür, dass er gefeuert wird, haben wir hier eine kleine Belohnung für ihn.
Gut, aber was ich jetzt meine, ist eine Sabotage im Sinne von, wir springen was in die Luft, weil da bist du noch ganz schnell irgendwo, wo du Menschen eben kostest. Das kann nicht sein.
Sabotage ist interessant. Weißt du, wo das Wort herkommt eigentlich?
Ich wusste es zumindest mal.
Und zwar von Shoe, halt französisch. Und das waren damals die Arbeiter, die dann ihre Schuhe in die Zahnräder, die in die Maschinen gesteckt haben und so die Maschinen zum Stillstand gebracht haben. Also das ist sozusagen, also Sabotage ist halt das Verklemmen, das Einführen von Schuhen ins Getriebe.
Was willst du sabotieren, um dagegen zu protestieren oder dagegen zu kämpfen, dass deine Freiheitsrechte eingeschränkt werden?
Na ja, es gibt, also auf YouTube gibt es ja auch nette Beispiele von Leuten, die etwa z.B. Kameraslamming betreiben und sich dabei filmen oder Kameras stehlen. Das ist auch ein beliebter Sport. Das war jetzt nur, ich hab's gefragt, was sind so Beispiele?
Es gab so eine Aktion, ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch dran erinnert, am Frankfurter Flughafen gab's mal einen großen Ausfall der Telekommunikation, weil leider ein Hauptglasfaserader durchtrennt wurde. Es könnte möglicherweise auch mit einem entsprechenden Bekennerbrief da...
Bekennerbriefe hinter technischen Pannen her schicken.
Das können wir machen. Das Problem ist doch, wenn ich in dem Moment am Frankfurter Flughafen sitze und drei Stunden Verspätung habe, dann werde ich sagen, diese Idioten sorgen dafür, dass ich drei Stunden Verspätung habe, um für irgendwelche abstrakten Freiheitsrechte zu kämpfen. Das irgendwie zu verbinden im Kopf.
Aber das sagen die Leute auch, wenn die Leute für mehr Lohn streiken oder für irgendwie kollegialisieren.
Das verstehen sie aber noch, weil sie selber Lohn beziehen.
Man muss sich natürlich die Ziele auch ein bisschen gezielter aussuchen. Klar, mein Lieblingsziel ist ganz großes Beispiel. Wenn Data Miner zu ruinieren oder z.B. die Schufa eine schöne E-Bombe von, wenn man mal rausfindet, wo die ihre Server geparkt haben. Oder dass man halt mal irgendwie halt so ein größeres Ziel...
Ja, so ein ERP Anschlag auf ein Rechenzentrum wäre schonmal was.
Ich hab hier nicht Angst oder Bedenken, dass bei solchen Aktionen, dass der gute Ruf vor dem Club da beschädigt wird. Also ich meine, der CCC ist ja praktisch eine Institution geworden. Mit solchen Aktionen, das erinnert mich immer so ein bisschen, der Vergleich hinkt jetzt, entschuldigt, aber so wie bei Greenpeace, die dann durch diese Aktionen natürlich eine Medienpräsenz erwirkt haben, aber das sind ja dann am Anfang keine Leute gewesen, mit denen man sich hinsetzt und das waren da keine seriösen Gesprächspartner. Und das seid ihr jetzt. Das würde dir im Prinzip...
Ja, die Frage ist aber, ob wir nicht davon auch gegeißelt sind ein bisschen. Also das ist ja glaube ich auch Sandros Ansatz, also dass wir uns wirklich zu wenig trauen.
Ihr seid jetzt nicht mehr, ihr seid nicht mehr die Bösen.
Ja, es passiert aber trotzdem nichts.
Ihr seid nicht mehr die Illegalen, die irgendwas komfort machen.
Ja, aber es passiert ihm nichts. Es ist kein Problem, muss sein, da in der Öffentlichkeit keine Diskussion. Ich meine, wenn du dir Greenpeace ansiehst, das ist jetzt ein schönes Beispiel. Die mögen zwar ein bisschen nicht so seriös sein, aber die sind enorm erfolgreich.
Also Sandro ist jetzt so ein Beispiel für, ich meine er ist nicht der Einzige, aber das erleben wir halt häufiger, dass Leute tatsächlich auf uns zukommen und sagen, macht mehr. Warum macht ihr nichts? Ihr seid irgendwie zu langweilig, zu etabliert, zu seriös. Ihr müsst doch endlich oder müsst wieder etwas mehr tun. Das ist tatsächlich eine Diskussion, die ich vorhin schon erwähnt, die auch im Club geführt wird, wieder mit zunehmender Häftigkeit. Wie weit sind wir gekommen bzw. auf welchem Wege erreichen wir unsere Ziele, die wir haben, am besten und was sind die Gefahren? Der Club ist ja auch nicht so eine stramme ideologische Organisation, sondern deckt ein riesiges politisches Spektrum auch ab.
Aber die HKX, die die Ethik durch euch formuliert und auch weiterentwickelt, das ist doch eine wunderbare Errungenschaft.
Ja, das denke ich auch.
Aber die Frage ist, ob sie uns nicht an manchen Stellen auch behindert.
Ja, aber Außenwirkung durch Medienpräsenz hat eine relativ kurze Halbwertzeit. Die Linux-Installation auf der Platte, die bleibt länger.
Aber es kommt nicht bei meiner Mutter an.
Ja, allerdings...
Es gibt unterschiedliche Zielegruppen.
Vielleicht ist das unser Job. Es kommt doch nicht bei meiner Ex-Freundin an. Es kommt bei den meisten Menschen nicht an. Bei den meisten Menschen, mit denen ich zu tun habe, kommt es nicht an, dass so eine Linux-Installation eigentlich eine tolle Sache ist und man damit zumindest schon mal, weiß ich nicht, ein bisschen mehr Datensicherheit gewährleistet für sich selbst. Es kommt bei den Leuten nicht an, selbst wenn ich die ganze Zeit mit einem Rechner rumrenne, wo Linux drauf ist. Ja, aber für Windows gibt es ja viel mehr Programme.
Ich meine, das Thema Seriosität ist jetzt auch nicht so unbedingt. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Club jetzt unbedingt so eine hochseriöse Institution ist. Also es gibt da, wenn ich es jetzt aus meinem Bereich, bin halt Technikforscher, wenn ich das da so ansehe, dann gibt es da immer viele Leute, die zwar unglaublich gerne mit dem Club Sachen machen würden. Also aus dem, aus dem ganz institutionellen Rahmen heraus, die dann aber den Club wiederum zu unseriös finden und zu paranoid und zu, ein bisschen zu komisch. Und also ich weiß nicht, ob diese Seriosität dann auch wirklich so konsequent ins letzten Ende ist.
Also es ist, ich denke schon, das ist schon was, was man mit Datensicherheit assoziiert.
Also praktisch.
Na ja, aber auch mit ein bisschen Verfolgungswahn und Verschwörungstheorien.
Andererseits, der Vorteil ist, wenn wir uns hinstellen würden, sagen, und wir haben von einem Politiker sämtliche Kreditkartendaten, so, dann würde man uns das wahrscheinlich erst mal glauben, ob es jetzt stimmt oder nicht. Aber die Frage ist, wenn wir sie haben, was machen wir damit?
Veröffentlichen.
Jemand anderen veröffentlichen lassen. Wir haben eine Kopie davon gekriegt, der sie...
Vielleicht wäre es ja auch sinnvoller, dem Politiker zu sagen, du, wir haben die Kreditkartendaten und bei der nächsten Abstimmung kannst du das ja mal im Hinterkopf behalten.
Das gibt euch Mühe, viele Themen zu versachlichen. Und das sieht man auch sehr schön auf euren Seiten.
Es gucken sich viele an und das ist aber bedauerlicherweise schon ein bisschen in Gefahr. So was ich meinte mit das Drehen an der Online-Gewaltspirale, die Druck erzeugt einfach Gegendruck. Und das kriegen wir im Moment eben auch zu spüren. Also möglicherweise stehen wir von einer weiteren Radikalisierung von einzelnen Leuten, die einfach das Gefühl haben, wir sind jetzt an der Grenze angekommen. Das Ende der Fahnenstange ist erreicht und wir werden jetzt was unternehmen. Und es ist uns so, wie Sandro sagt, jetzt ist mir alles egal. So, aber mir reicht's.
Aber die Geschichte zeigt doch, dass man das im Prinzip, ich wüsste nicht, wo man sowas jemals gewonnen hätte.
Also da gibt's in der Geschichte, wenn man jetzt mit Geschichte anfängt, es gibt ja ganz, ganz viele Beispiele, wo man auf die Art und Weise gewonnen hat. Also die Sabotage zum Beispiel, diese Geschichte ist ganz interessant. Dann gab's auch die Ludisten in England, die irgendwie Maschinen zerstört haben. Das waren so Weber, die dann irgendwie gegen Webmaschinen protestiert haben. Und da gibt's also in der Geschichte...
Trotzdem gibt's da keine Textilindustrie mehr.
Na, das ist dann später aus anderen Gründen gescheitert. Aber trotzdem gibt's schon noch genug Beispiele, dass man jetzt nicht gleich sagen muss, dann werfe ich gleich die Flinte ins Korn, da ekelts weg. Und ich meine, was ich auch noch sagen wollte, was mir persönlich auch immer auffällt, ist, dass es beim Club auch so eine ganz... so ein bisschen eine Verschiebung gibt in der Innenwahrnehmung. Also da gibt's auch gerade von jungen Programmierern oder sowas. Also alle, die so ein bisschen den CCC kennen, dann ist es immer gleich so ein bisschen so eine verschwörerische Einheit. Und da gibt's dann so eine Innenwahrnehmung, weil man diese ganzen Blogs liest und unglaublich viel im Netz sieht und sowas. Aber das deckt sich nicht mit der Außenwahrnehmung. Das kommt so im Club immer so vor, als wäre da unglaublich viel am Machen und unglaublich viel Diskussion. Aber das ist nicht der Fall. Das sind eigentlich immer nur die gleichen. Und das sind auch international immer nur die gleichen. Das ist so eine Community, die sich gegenseitig hält und gegenseitig so ein bisschen auf... Ich will jetzt nicht sagen aufwiegelt, aber halt... So eine verzerrte Wahrnehmung...
Das Podcasting Phänomen.
Ja, so eine verzerrte Wahrnehmung existiert, die einfach außen nicht existent ist. Der Durchschnittsbürger kennt den Chaos Computer Club halt als so ein bisschen, naja, komische Wandeln von...
Der Umstand, dass ich seit vielen Jahren eben hier beim Chaos Radio dabei bin, führt natürlich auch dazu, dass mich Kollegen anderer Medien anrufen und Kontakt zum Chaos Computer Club hergestellt haben wollen. Und das wollen sie besonders dann, wenn es um Killerspiele geht zum Beispiel. Das heißt, die Wahrnehmung auch dann im Medienbetrieb, also die Wahrnehmung, die der Chaos Computer Club im Medienbetrieb hat, ist dann auch eher so, ja, die kann man mal zu Killerspielen fragen. Also dass der CCC im Grunde sich gerne als Bürgerrechtsorganisation versteht. Oder verstehen würde, zum großen Teil als Bürgerrechtsorganisation verstehen würde. Das kommt nicht an. Das kommt nicht an, solange man den Leuten das nicht hinsetzt.
Das erlebe ich gerade auch im täglichen Betrieb sozusagen bei den Presseanfragen. Es geht ganz viel um diese Online-Durchsuchung, wo die Behörden einen heimischen PC durchsuchen wollen. Und da ist immer die Frage, wie kann man sich dagegen schützen? Und was kann der Bürger tun? Man kann sich dagegen nicht schützen. Man kann übrigens die Regierung stürzen, abwählen, andere Regierung wählen. Das ist das Einzige, was zuverlässig hilft. Anti-Viren-Programme helfen nicht. Dann sagen sie, naja, das ist ja nicht so das, was wir hören wollten. Schönen Dank. Ja, sorry. Aber es ist halt so.
Es ist...
Gut, man kann... Das war jetzt ein schönes politisches Statement. Aber man kann natürlich sehr wohl einiges tun. Aber es stimmt schon. Nachhaltig wirklich dauerhaft... Also eine nachhaltige, dauerhafte Lösung ist...
Klar, politisch sagen wollen wir nicht. Darf nicht sein, ist nicht angesagt. Das ist das Beste, was hilft.
Danke Joachim erstmal.
Und gute Nacht.
Also bis zum 10. März ist ja noch ein Weilchen hin. Aber wir wollen es jetzt mal rechtzeitig sagen, damit alle Bescheid wissen. Nicht, dass es dann wieder heißt. Ey, sowas sagt einem ja keiner. Wenn ich das gewusst hätte, hätte ich mir auch schon mal garten. Also sagen wir es lieber gleich, damit sich auch wirklich alle drauf einstellen können und Bescheid wissen. Ist ja auch nur fair, wenn alle auf dem gleichen Wissenstand sind und jeder in Ruhe planen kann und weiß, ja, hier, 10. März, da bin ich ja. Wenn einer dann nicht kann, ist auch okay. Aber man sollte es halt früh genug bekannt geben, damit sich auch jeder drauf...
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Fritz präsentiert The Killers. Samstag, 10. März, ab 21 Uhr, im Hangar 2, Flughafen Tempelhof. Muss ja immer gesagt werden. Fritz.
Mit Mario Bartsch.
Die führenden Spitzenverbände der Muslime haben ein Treffen mit der evangelischen Kirche in Deutschland abgesagt. Hintergrund ist ein Positionspapier der evangelischen Kirche zum Verhältnis von Christentum und Islam. Darin wird das Ziel eine gute Nachbarschaft genannt. Flankt wird aber auch Kritik zu üben, wenn Menschenrechte in Frage gestellt werden. Der Vorsitzende des Islam Rates, Kizilkaya, sprach von einem Dokument der Abgrenzung. Der Absturz eines Stahlträgers von der Fassade des Berliner Hauptbahnhofs hätte nach Einschätzung des Architekten von Gerkan vermieden werden können. Von Gerkan sagte vor dem Verkehrsausschuss des Bundestages, er habe ursprünglich Haltevorrichtungen für die Träger geplant. Diese seien aber unter der Regie der Bahn bei der weiteren Bauausführung weggelassen worden. Bahnvorstandsmitglied Wieshäu wies jede Verantwortung zurück. Potsdams Stadtverordnete haben im dritten Anlauf einem Landtagsneubau auf dem Areal des früheren Stadtschlosses zugestimmt. Es gab 29 Ja-Stimmen, 16 Ablehnungen und 3 Enthaltungen. Zum Sport in der Fußball-Bundesliga hat Hertha BSC auswärts gegen Hannover 96 0 zu 5 verloren. Enneke Cottbus trennte sich vom Hamburger SV 1 zu 1. In den weiteren Mittwochspapieren spielten Leverkusen gegen Bremen 0 zu 2, Mainz gegen Dortmund 1 zu 0 und Schalke gegen Aachen 2 zu 1. Der FC Bayern München hat Trainer Felix Magath gefeuert. Der Verein gab die Entscheidung am Nachmittag bekannt. Bis zum Saisonende wird der ehemalige Trainer Ottmar Hitzfeld die Bayern leiten. Auch Borussia Mönchengladbach braucht einen neuen Trainer. Jupp Heynckes erklärte am Mittag seinen Rücktritt. In der Basketball-Bundesliga hat Alba Berlin nach einer Heimniederlage gegen Spaniens Basketball-Topteam Real Madrid kaum noch Chancen auf den Viertelfinaleinzug im ULEP Cup. Die Berliner verloren das Achtelfinal-Hinspiel 65 zu 74.
Letter.
Beim letzten Mal war ein Wort zu wenig, jetzt war ein Wort zu viel, was mich irritierte.
Ja, manchmal fehlen einem die Worte.
Heute Nacht kommen von Norden immer mehr Wolken zu uns und die bringen auch Regen mit. Die Tiefstwerte liegen bei 4 bis 2 Grad. Dazu ist es ziemlich windig. Am Tag werden meist sonnig und trocken, bei Höchstwerten bis 8 Grad. Auffolgenden Autobahnabschnitten sind derzeit Schwertransporte unterwegs, die nicht überholt werden können. A10 Schönefelder Kreuz Richtung Schwanebeck zwischen Schönefelder Kreuz und Raststätte Seeberg. Und A13 Dresden Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Schwarzheide und Schönefelder Kreuz. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin, Templo Schöneberg. Die Motzner Straße ist in Höhenunst auf der Ring nach einem Unfall immer noch gesperrt. Sonst überall eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Mario, drei Minuten nach der Beinz.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6 dann Fritz in Berlin.
Hat der Nasi Goreng gesungen eigentlich? Hat er nicht gesungen. Ihr hört's, Chaosradio 120. Ziviler Ungehorsam für Anfänger ist das Thema heute Abend. Was hat denn eigentlich, hat irgendjemand mal die Ideen mitgeschrieben, die wir hatten? Also Politikerfingerabdrücke sammeln, Politiker DNA sammeln.
Ja, wir wollen einfach alle Daten von den Leuten haben. Wir wollen die beobachten. Wir wollen sie sozusagen, es heißt ja, es gibt diesen Begriff zur Gefahrenabwehr. Wir wollen natürlich auch sämtliche Gefahren abwehren von den Politikern und dass sie auch möglicherweise kriminell werden könnten, wenn wir ihnen gar nicht die Gelegenheit geben und sie gar nicht in Versuchung kommen lassen. Deswegen wollen wir gerne alle Daten sammeln von den Politikern.
Genau, und wenn die nichts zu verbergen haben, dann haben sie natürlich auch nichts zu befürchten.
Genau.
So sieht das mal aus.
Man könnte sie ja gleich mal fragen, ob sie die nicht sowieso offenlegen wollen.
Nee, wollen sie ja nicht. Da werden sie ja ständig nach gefragt. Also sie wollen ja noch nicht mal ihre Nebeneinkünfte offenlegen.
Und auch sonst eigentlich keine Akten rausgeben. Oder nur, wenn der Bürger 500 Euro Gebühren dafür bezahlt.
0331 70 97 110 ist unsere Telefonnummer, wenn ihr mit uns sprechen wollt. Die Frage an euch war ja auch, was unternehmt ihr eigentlich? Oder was für eine Idee habt ihr, was man dagegen unternehmen kann, das mit uns veranstaltet wird, was mit uns veranstaltet wird zur Zeit? Und dran ist der Robert. Hallo Robert.
Ihr hattet auch noch die Frage gestellt, was um so nervt in der letzten Zeit.
Das war die Eingangsfrage ganz am Anfang der Sendung.
Aber erzähl, ja.
Und zwar, was mich einigermaßen nervt, ist, dass so immer wieder kleine Teile von diesen riesigen Datenmengen einfach so nach unten rauskropfen und keiner wirklich davon Notiz nimmt.
Hast du ein Beispiel?
Das habe ich allerdings. Das hat mich ziemlich geärgert. Das ist an sich keine große Sache. Aber so in der Addition kann daraus einiges werden, denke ich. Ich mache Online-Banking. Das finde ich einfach relativ bequem. So von zu Hause Überweisungen machen, alles ganz schön und habe dafür natürlich auch meine Daten bei der Bank hinterlegt und die können ja auch damit arbeiten.
Ist ja alles gut.
Jetzt ist nur die Sache, wenn ich mich da so anmelde. Ich muss mich ja mal einloggen, bevor ich da an meinen Online-Banking rankomme. Gebe ich Konto-Nummer ein, gebe ich meinen Kern-Nord ein. Das interessante ist dann aber, wenn die Daten ich eingebe nicht stimmen. Gebe ich völligen Unsinn ein, aber aus Konto-Nummer einfach 08154711 kommt da die Meldung irgendwie sinngemäß immer diese Konto-Nummer gibt es nicht und so können sie sich nicht einloggen. Gebe ich jetzt meine Konto-Nummer oder eine andere Konto-Nummer, die es gibt, ein und ein falsches Kern-Word dazu, kommt immer die Meldung, das Kern-Word ist falsch. Was natürlich im Klartext heißt, okay, das Konto gibt es. Derjenige, dem dieses Konto gehört, der macht auch Online-Banking, aber das Kern-Word stimmt halt nicht. Jetzt könnte man sich natürlich auf den Weg machen und einfach mal Konto-Nummern sammeln und durchprobieren oder das Ganze auch automatisiert machen. Und erstmal schauen, wer macht denn überhaupt Online-Banking und welche Konten gibt es denn überhaupt? Und so dann eventuell, wenn man diese Ziele dann hat, so sich überlegen, was man noch an weiteren Unfug damit treiben könnte. Ich hatte das versucht auch schon mal, eine Ansprechpartnerin von der Bank zu schildern. Und der war das aber überhaupt nicht klar zu machen. Die meinte nur, na ja, bevor man eine Überweisung machen kann, braucht man ja eh noch die Tannen. Und da kann man ja überhaupt nichts machen an dem Konto. Aber dass ich versucht habe, dieser Frau zu schildern, dass es hier um Datenschutz geht, dass sie letztendlich eine Information über meine, einen Bankbehalten da nach draußen geben, das war der Dame irgendwie nicht zu vermitteln. Und die wurde dann am Ende schon einigermaßen ungehalten.
Also gängige Praxis ist eigentlich, dass man sagt, da ist was falsch, entweder Passwort oder Login oder Konto. Nur mal. Und man sagt aber nicht, was davon falsch ist. Also das erleichtert die Sache auch ein bisschen. Also das ist einfach ein anwerkliches Problem da. Aber könnte man vielleicht, ja, vielleicht mag sich da mal jemand ransetzen. Welche Bank ist das?
Ich hab gerade noch ein paar andere hier durchprobiert, als ich in der Warteschleife war.
Also ich hab die Erfahrung bei der Berliner Bank selbst gepasst.
Die Berliner Sparkasse scheint die gleiche Software zu haben, sieht zumindest genauso aus. Ich hab es gerade auch nochmal bei der Postbank versucht, da ist auch das gleiche, da kriegt man auch die zwei verschiedenen Meldungen.
Na dann ran, Leute. www.bundestag.de gibt es die Liste der Bundestagsabgeordneten. Wir wollen alle Daten.
Wo schicken wir die denn dann hin?
Mail at ccc.de Mail at ccc.de.
Jetzt gerade hat sich mein Rechner aufgehangen. Das ist der Rechner, auf dem auch die Telefonanlage läuft. Das passiert hier immer nach halb eins. Ich weiß nicht. Ist klar.
Wenn ihr schon die Daten der ganzen Politiker sammelt, wie illegal und wie strafbar wäre es denn, die auch mal für eine Paybackkarte oder ähnliches anzumelden? Das fällt Herr Schäuble mal seine Paybackkarte, kriegt Herr Beckstein seine Paybackkarte.
Die werden das alle haben. Das ist doch alles eine ganz tolle Sache und wäre nichts zu verbergen oder zu befürchten.
Die gehen ja nicht einkaufen. Das Problem ist langweilig.
Na ja, aber man könnte sie einfach immer wieder mit all ihren Daten, an die man rankommt, über alle möglichen Gelegenheiten anmelden.
Woher willst du wissen, dass die nicht einkaufen gehen? Kann das mal jemand flickern? Bundestagsabgeordnete beim Einkaufen.
Genau, wir wollen alles wissen, was sie haben, was sie einkaufen und mit wie sie es bezahlen, mit Kreditkarte, mit EC-Karte.
Ist das eigentlich in irgendeiner Form illegal oder halblegerhalt, diese Informationen zu beschaffen, also zu sammeln und zu speichern, zu veröffentlichen? Nö, aber zu sagen, ich habe Otto Schiele dabei beobachtet, wie er 300 Gramm Rock vorgekauft hat.
Also wir haben ja diesen Stalking-Paragraph, da müssen wir mal schauen, ob der möglicherweise vielleicht genau so eine Sache unter Strafe stellen könnte. Ja, aber so what, ich mein, es gibt anonyme Remailer, schickt uns die Sachen, wir sammeln das vertrauensvoll für euch.
Ja, wir danken für deinen Anruf. Ich kann dich jetzt noch nicht mal aus der Leitung schmeißen. Weg bitte einfach auf. Und wer jetzt immer noch in der Leitung hängt, ihr braucht nicht davon auszugehen, dass ich hier gerade, oder? Doch, der Zustand ändert sich wieder. Hey, es funktioniert wieder. Tadaa, wo wir beim Data Mining waren. Sandro sagte eben, es wäre ja auch mal eine schöne Sache, vielleicht einen Data Miner zu ruinieren. Also einfach die Leute, die Daten sammeln, zu ruinieren. Benjamin, du hast was zur Datensammlung in Unternehmen.
Ich habe eigentlich was zur Datensammlung in Unternehmen. Das ist richtig. Jaja, aber ich wollte doch nochmal auf diesen, wir sind jetzt schon wieder, oder die Ethikdebatte ist schon wieder fast vorbei, aber darauf wollte ich nochmal kurz Bezug nehmen. Weil ich finde, das ist eine ganz schwierige Diskussion, dass man sich auf der einen Seite eher über Leute aufregt, die halt bestimmte Regeln biegen und brechen und auf der anderen Seite aber sich andere Szenarien ausdenkt, unter denen man eben Regeln biegen und brechen darf. Da fängt man dann an, wieder die Welt in Gut und Böse zu unterteilen. Und naja, da gibt es auch andere Leute, die das machen, die dann, ich weiß nicht, Kriege im Namen von Gut und Böse führen. Und ja, ich finde, um da glaubwürdig zu bleiben, auch sich selbst gegenüber, muss man da sich dann schon an die Regeln halten, wie es gibt.
Also da ist jetzt ein bisschen sehr weit ausgeholt, uns dann gleich zu Kriegsverbrechern abzustempeln.
Nee, du, ich will dir das Ganze, die Debatte an sich, finde ich ja sehr sinnvoll. Ich will das gar nicht, es ist sehr überspitzt, das ist mir schon klar.
Im Grunde ist dein Argument, wenn wir an der Hackerethik schrauben und sie vielleicht zeitgemäßer machen, dann ist das nichts anderes als das, was der Bundesinnenminister versucht, nämlich am Grundgesetz zu schrauben. Für seine Begriffe zeitgemäß zu machen.
Ja, nur dass halt, also, verstehe mich nicht falsch, ich nehme jetzt einen ein bisschen extremen Gegenpunkt ein, eigentlich bin ich auf eurer Seite, in Anführungsstrichen so, aber...
Welcher, wir haben gerade zwei.
Ihr seid ein, ihr seid ein, also ich meine, wir leben in einer Demokratie und theoretisch kann jeder, der Lust hat, sich irgendwie auch daran beteiligen und zum Politiker auserkühren lassen. Und deswegen ist das noch ein bisschen was anderes. Das sind demokratische Prozesse, die da abgehen. Und ja, wenn man sich als Einzelner hinsetzt oder als eine Gruppe von Menschen hinsetzt und sagt, ich schaue mir jetzt an, was ich finde, was gut und böse ist und was vertretbar ist und was nicht vertretbar ist, dann mag das im Einzelfall völlig überzeugend klingen. Aber ich finde, das ist eine gefährliche Richtung, in die man dann geht.
Da sind wir wieder bei Realus und Fundis.
Genau, die Diskussion ist es. Das ist dann eine Frage, ob man ein bisschen realpolitischer werden soll oder man lieber an den Idealen festhalten soll.
Ja, also generell dieses Politiker-Bashing, also auch das Datensammeln von Politikern und so. Ich kann es gut verstehen, ich reg mich da auch gerne drüber auf. Aber wie gesagt, das sind im Großteil Leute, die in der Wirtschaft sicherlich deutlich mehr Geld verdienen könnten.
Nee, die würden da keine Jobs kriegen. Entschuldigung, aber ich bin fest davon überzeugt, dass der größte Teil des politischen Personals es so weit in einem ganz normalen Unternehmen, das am Markt sich behaupten muss, es nicht bringen würde. Die haben alle Jobs, die sie wollen schon.
Aber die haben die Jobs nicht, weil sie Qualifikation haben.
Die haben alle Jobs, die sie nicht bekommen hätten, wenn sie nicht vorher Abgeordnete gewesen wären. Das ist nicht so, dass sie diese Jobs aus besonderer Qualifikation haben und dann erst Abgeordnete geworden sind, sondern die haben die Jobs, weil sie Abgeordnete sind, weil da Interessen vertreten werden.
Ja, aber umgekehrt funktioniert es ja auch nicht. Also erfolgreiche Wirtschaftsführer haben in der Politik nun in der Regel auch nicht viele Chancen. Also es ist schon ein spezieller Beruf, der spezielle Talente erfordert.
Ja, aber da so eine separate Gruppe zu schaffen, das finde ich eben, das trägt nur zu dieser Dämonisierung bei. Also irgendwie, wir sind Teil des Landes, wir können auch uns engagieren, wenn wir wollen, in der Politik und zu sagen, ja, das sind die Politiker, die machen alle ihr Ding. Ja, ich finde, das ist so Teil der...
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall auch, also die Politiker so in der Form gibt es tatsächlich nicht, aber dann werde ich gleich wieder verdächtigt, wenn ich anfange, Politiker zu differenzieren, dass das schon wieder zu kompliziert ist, möglicherweise.
Naja, das ist gar nicht immer so kompliziert. Also das ist ja auch jedem klar, dass es nicht die Politiker als homogene Masse gibt, aber was es zum Beispiel gibt, das sind die Fraktionen und ihre Disziplin, die da eingehalten wird, wo dann auf einmal der einzelne Politiker nicht mehr nach seinem Gewissen entscheidet. Und da muss man ihn auch fragen, warum er das nicht tut.
Oder es wird halt alles sowieso eine Ebene höher entschieden, nämlich entweder auf europäischer Ebene oder sogar auf der Rad oder noch weiter.
Auf europäischer Ebene wird aber auch nichts entschieden, was die Mitgliedsländer nicht haben wollen.
Ja, ja, ja, nein. Also es ist immer schwierig zu sagen, was davon irgendwie Wirkung und Ursache ist. Aber bei den Reisepässen war es ja so, dass es natürlich auch von Deutschland ausgegangen ist und quasi über den Umweg Europa wieder zurückgekommen ist.
Ja, und wenn es die Mitgliedstaaten nicht hätten haben wollen, hätte es das nicht gegeben. Auch da passiert ja Demokratie. Das ist ja nicht so, dass da irgendwie eine zentrale Instanz irgendwo in Brüssel sitzt und sagt, so wir machen das jetzt so, egal ob ihr das wollt oder nicht. Also die Bildungspolitik in Deutschland ist so desolat, weil die Deutschen das so wollen. Das darf man nie vergessen.
Gut, also tut mir leid, dass ich da nochmal so in die Grundlagen gehen.
Ist ja richtig, ist ja ein Thema zu sagen.
Ursprünglich ist richtig, wollte ich eigentlich was zum Data Mining sagen. Also es ging ja die meiste Zeit wirklich um den Staat, was der so für Sachen anstellt. Da kann man sich auch Sorgen drüber machen, sehe ich auch so. Wobei ich denke, das Niveau, auf dem wir uns hier in Deutschland Sorgen machen, ist schon ein ziemlich hohes. Das ist auch gut so sicherlich. Aber wo ich mir doch noch mehr Angst und Gedanken mache, sind eben wirklich die Unternehmen, was da im Hintergrund abläuft, die eben wirklich ihre Daten fröhlich sammeln und vernetzen, wo keiner eine Ahnung hat, was sich da überhaupt schon alles verbunden hat. Und wie es jetzt eben auch schon langsam Unternehmen gibt, die sich eben diese Daten alle zusammen kaufen und das dann an Leute verkaufen, die eben Geld dafür bezahlen. Also ich war jetzt gerade in den USA, da bin ich irgendwie über eine Zeitungsanzeige gestolpert. Da kann man eben Backgroundchecks von Leuten machen für eine gewisse Summe Geld. Das wird leider nicht angegeben, um eben sicherzustellen, dass das Kindermädchen, was man einstellt, keinen betrunkenen Vorstraf und was auch immer hat. Und was da für Datenbanken schon bei den Unternehmen schlummern, das sind so die Sachen, die jenseits von der Regulierung irgendwie abgehen. Und da mache ich mir eigentlich noch viel mehr Sorgen.
Klar, wir brauchen natürlich auch schlagkräftigere Datenschutzbeauftragte, die da irgendwie hinterher sind. Wir brauchen aber auch vor allem Sanktionierungsmöglichkeiten. Das heißt also wirklich auch härtere Strafen, die auch wirklich abschreckend wirken für Datenverbrecher. Das heißt also Firmen, die mit diesen Daten umgehen in einer Weise, wie es nicht sein sollte oder wie wir es nicht wollen, wie es auch nicht erlaubt ist teilweise.
Aber es ist natürlich auch schwierig, da erst mal Transparenz hinzukriegen, also wirklich auch zu sehen, wer was hat und wo. Das kriegst du ja so ohne weiteres auch nicht raus. Die sitzen ja auch sonst wo.
Klar, aber es gibt auch keine ernsthaften Unternehmungen, das irgendwie zu machen. Also eine Firma muss ja auch nicht nachweisen, wo sie die Daten her hat.
Und da sind es dann doch wieder die Politiker.
Klar, die Politiker ist ja gefragt, was zu machen, sicher.
Auf welche Weise kann man denn einen Data Miner ruinieren?
Na, mit sinnlosen Informationen füttern. Oder ganz einfach die Hardware schmelzen. Ich weiß nicht, gibt es eigentlich E-Bomben schon?
Nicht für den Hausgebrauch. Das ist schwierig.
Was ist das? Achso, das ist das, was Axel und Andreas Burg vor paar Monaten diskutiert haben, wie man mit einem Kupferrohr und so was einen EMP her... Ich erinnere mich. Nur wenn du den Datenbestand der Schufa wegschminst...
Ja, das funktioniert so nicht. Da gibt es genügend Backup-Ebenrechenzentren.
Schufa ist eine harte Nuss.
Das wäre das perfekte Ziel, weil selbst die Leute, die da keinen Eintrag haben, finden es irgendwie doof. Das ist dann wahrscheinlich die Sympathie der Bevölkerung eventuell hinter dir.
Ich steh da auch drin. An meiner eigenen Sympathie hätte ich da auch.
Du bist auch die Bevölkerung.
Wie gesagt, interessanterweise kommen die Aufrufe weniger aus dem Inneren des Clubs als mehr aus dem Umfeld, wo gesagt wird, macht mehr ich bin. Auch eher der Meinung, dass das ein schlüpfriger Pfad ist, wenn man da einmal seinen Fuß draufsetzt, dass man dann ins Rutschen kommen kann und nicht weiß, wo man dann wieder zum Stehen kommt. Also eigentlich Aktionen, ja, auf jeden Fall, aber sie müssen vor allem auch witzig sein. Und das, ja.
Es müssen ja gar keine Aktionen sein, um Leute aufzurütteln, sondern beispielsweise an den Punkten, wo Aufklärung nicht funktioniert hat im Vorfeld, vielleicht wenigstens eine Gegenmaßnahme anbieten. Also das, was wir vorhin auch schon mal hatten, dass man sagt, wenn wir sehen, dass da irgendwo eine unsichere Software, der Bundestrojaner beispielsweise, da versucht die Bundesregierung, versucht meinen Rechner auszuspionieren. Ich habe nicht die leiseste Ahnung, wie ich mich dagegen wehren kann. Wenn der CCC hingeht und sagt, hier ist das Tool, das installierst du auf deinem Rechner.
Ja, und dann lehnen sich alle zurück und sagen, okay, es ist ja prima, jetzt kann mir nichts passieren. Und dann haben wir nichts gewonnen.
Dann kann die Bundesregierung dich nicht mehr ausschleifen.
Zum Bundestrojaner vielleicht noch das Ding richtig ist. Eine Regierung, die sowas wie den Bundestrojaner ins Feld führt, gehört tatsächlich einfach abgeschafft, dauerhaft. Aber wenn das nicht gelingt, im Moment ist die Gefahr eher nicht so groß, dass das wirklich zum Erfolg führen wird. Dazu sind die Mittel, die sie dafür im Moment eingestellt haben. Die Haushaltsmittel reichen bei Weitem nicht aus. Mit 200.000 Euro etwa werden sie nichts Vernünftiges auf die Reihe kriegen. Die wird die Spezifikation von dem Ding allein verschlingen. Von daher ist die Gefahr im Moment nicht akut. Virenhersteller, wichtiger war zum Beispiel die Frage, Frank war da auch sehr aktiv, wir haben gefragt, ob denn möglicherweise von Seiten der Regierung Druck auf wie Antiviren-Software-Hersteller ausgeübt wird, diesen Bundestrojaner zu ignorieren. Da sieht die Situation aber so aus, dass dazu die Bundesregierung nicht in der Lage ist. Erstens, weil die meisten im Ausland sitzen. Das heißt, die werden sich nicht darum, es ist denen scheißegal, ob jetzt die Bundesregierung da einen Trojaner macht oder nicht. Sondern der wird einfach erkannt werden von normaler Viren-Software. Insofern ist das auch ein bisschen im Moment ein Papiertiger, der da aufgemacht wird. Aber schlimm ist, dass überhaupt so was ernsthaft diskutiert wird. Und das zeigt leider auch, dass im Moment bei den Leuten der Sachverstand gleich mehrfach. Es ist doppelt daneben einfach, darüber nachzudenken. Erstens, weil es technisch im Moment völliger Blödsinn ist, was diskutiert wird, die Mittel falsch sind und auch noch das ganze moralisch, ethisch einfach.
Die Grundidee ist einfach völlig...
Ja, aber auch nicht mal darüber wird sich aufgeregt.
Wenig, wenig, ja.
Weil, ach so, genau, da fiel mir noch eines. Es gibt halt, also die, wer halt sozusagen heimliche Hausdurchsuchungen gemacht hat, war die Stasi. Da war das halt oft üblich. Und ich meine, aus gutem Grund gibt es halt... Darf die Polizei eben nicht heimlich die Wohnung durchsuchen, während man nicht da ist, mit einem Nachschlüssel mal eben gucken. Ist da vielleicht irgendwas? Und wenn ja, dann wird nochmal offiziell wiedergekommen. Das sind halt Geheimdienstmethoden. Und die gehören einfach nicht in den Polizeiasenal.
Es gab ja in Kanada jetzt diese schöne Geschichte mit der Hausdurchsuchung vor der Hausdurchsuchung. Da fliegen die jetzt mit so hochsensiblen Infrarotkameras über Häuser und machen Aufnahmen und wenn es dann irgendwo besonders viel Hitze generiert wird, dann ist das schon mal so ein Verdacht, dass da irgendwie so ein Haschbauerwach über wohnen könnte und da machen sie dann Hausdurchsuchung. Und das hatten sie jetzt schon mehrfach gemacht. Und jetzt ist in Kanada so eine Diskussion, ob das nicht schon als Hausdurchsuchung gilt, wenn man mit einer Infrarotkamera über die Häuser fliegt.
Interessanter Punkt. Da gibt es auch immer wieder Meldungen, dass Grenzhubschrauber Plantagen in Grenznähe finden, weil die eben mitten in der Nacht Infrarot dermaßen strahlen. Das ist auch schon passiert. Damit sind wir am Ende. Das war Chaosradio 120. Chaosradio 121 gibt es am letzten Mittwoch im Februar. Das ist der 28. Montag, der 26. 27. 28.
Vielleicht noch mal ganz kurzer Hinweis, für die, die von Anfang an nicht dabei waren, es gibt dieses Jahr wieder ein Camp, das Chaos Communication Camp, ein großes Zeltlager für Hacker sozusagen. Das findet statt Anfang August, 8. bis 12. August, bei Finofort in der Nähe von Berlin. Und schaut auf events.ccc.de. Da gibt es denn die fast täglichen oder zumindest im Moment noch wöchentlichen Updates dazu.
Die Sendung gibt es als Podcast. Die Sendung gibt es auch als Weiß der Geier, was für komische Sachen noch. Auch zum Nachlesen im Zweifelsfall. Näheres findet ihr auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Da findet ihr auch die Ankündigung auf die nächste Sendung. Es gibt einen Wiki, da könnt ihr euch an der nächsten Sendung auch beteiligen. Das wird die 121 sein. Links dazu auch auf der Chaosradio.
Wenn ihr uns noch was schreiben wollt, dann bitte an chaosradio.ccc.de.
Vielen Dank, Frank. Vielen Dank, Pavel. Vielen Dank, Sandro. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit. Gute Nacht. Du darfst dir jetzt auswählen, was die letzte Platte ist, Frank. Sag einfach eine Zahl zwischen eins und wie viel auch immer da auf dieser CD drauf sind.
Ja, sieben.
Sieben. Das ist ja super, dass wir direkt an der sieben sind. Gute Nacht.
Vielen Dank.
Ich muss ja sagen, die Zeichen Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf, aber das wisst ihr sicher.